[Musique]
gaël giraud bonsoir moi ça nous recevons
pour une chaîne internet qui s'appelle
thinker view nous sommes en direct
est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succinctement
bien dire oh je suis l'ancien économiste
en chef de l'agencé française de
développement
je suis directeur de recherche au cnrs
je suis prêtre jésuite je viens de
soutenir une thèse de théologie un
doctorat de théologie au centre sèvres
il ya deux jours qui a été le sujet de
cette thèse docteur le sujet s'est
décomposé un monde en commun et le sous
titre c'était une théologie politique de
l'anthropocène donc la grande question
c'est
pourrait dire face à la crise écologique
que la nôtre aujourd'hui
composé des institutions qui permettent
de prendre soin des commun des
ressources que nous voulons partager en
commun ça c'est une c'est certainement
une partie de la solution est la
question que je me suis posée comme
théologien c est ce que le christianisme
est une ressource spirituelle pour
alimenter l'énergie et la créativité la
ressource sur l'intériorité et
spirituelle dont on a besoin pour
inventer ces communs et les institutions
qui vont avec alors moi je vais vous
poser une question est ce que le vatican
est prêt
appliquez votre prospective est ce que
le vatican a fait un geste par rapport à
l'anthropocène main on à feu un ami
jacques blamont qui était parti jusqu'au
vatican pour dire voilà vous êtes les
maîtres de la propagande depuis 2000 ans
est ce que vous pouvez faire passer un
message à vos ouailles
moi en tant que biographe officiel de
galilée
est-ce que vous pouvez passer un message
à vos oreilles pour ralentir la
consommation de viande déjà ce genre de
petit geste est ce que vous pensez que
le vatican est prêt
à rentrer dans l'ère du 21ème siècle
alors le vatican c'est un objet complexe
c'est une grande administration qui a vu
siècles d'histoire à la tête du vatican
vous avez le pape aujourd'hui le pape la
réponse est certainement oui j'ai une
audience avec lui au début du mois de
septembre le 3 septembre avec des gens
vous connaissent et juliette binoche
audrey pulvar
et les positions qu'il a prises devant
nous avec nous dans la discussion montre
que très clairement lui il est prêt à
avancer dans cette direction il ya eu
des classes donc d'abord évidemment vous
connaissez l'encyclique lahoud est aussi
qui date de 2015 maintenant qu'il ya
cinq ans qui a fait date quand même au
niveau international sur la question
écologique disons magie des amis écolos
qui m'ont dit jamais nous autres on a
réussi à publier un tel texte
depuis 40 ans d'activisme et de
militantisme par ailleurs depuis lors le
pauvre françois aussi lancé ce qu'on
appelle le synode sur l'amazonie dont
les conclusions seront extrêmement
fortes et il prend position en faveur de
la protection de l'amazonie ce que ne
fait évidemment pas jaillir bonnaroo et
puis dans la discussion qu'on a eue avec
lui
il nous a dit des choses absolument
incroyable enfin du genre il ya une
logique commune entre l'exploitation des
enfants
l'abandon des personnes âgées
la croyance que les marchés vont
résoudre tous nos problèmes et qu'on
peut se ne pas faire attention à la
question d'un pacte social et écologique
de nos décisions économiques et
d'exploitation des femmes
donc il a pris les positions qu'on
pourrait dire est qu féministe très
clair pour moi je crois que le poids de
françois lille est tout à fait prêts à
nous suivre dans cette direction le
reste du vatican c'est une autre affaire
c'est une administration compliquée dans
laquelle on trouve de tout comme dans
toutes les administrations on
va en revanche et sur les blanchiments
d'argent par les banques parce que le
vatican continue de blanchir de l'argent
la réponse est probablement non
sincèrement parce que le pape françois a
essayé de faire le ménage dans la banque
du vatican a remplacé le patron de cette
banque qui était certainement quelqu'un
d'assez corrompu par un autre qu'il est
je l'espère en tout cas beaucoup moins
et donc en tout cas si c'est pas
complètement réglé on est en voie je
pense autant que je sache de résolution
de cette question en fait vous faites
allusion à une enquête qui a été menée
qui vient d'être publiée par le
consortium des dj voilà ici et j'ai donc
des journalistes d'investigation qui
montre que il ya cinq ou six banques sur
la planète qui ont organisé de manière
extrêmement systématique depuis une
trentaine d'années maintenant du
blanchiment d'argent sale sur la
totalité la planète là dedans vous
retrouvez hsbc jp morgan
deutsche bank c'est ça qui m'intéresse
le plus les montants sont colossaux on
parle de plus de 2000 milliards de
dollars c'est l'équivalent c'est la
taille en gros du fin c'est l'ordre de
grandeur du pib français bon moi ce qui
m'intéresse le plus dans cette affaire
c'est deutsche bank pourquoi parce que
ça fait des années que dans la sphère
financière beaucoup de gens soupçonnent
la banque de faire l'intermédiaire entre
par exemple les oligarques russes et le
monde occidental sans que les autorités
publiques allemandes n'est jugé utile
d'aller mettre leur nez là dedans et
donc c'est quelque chose d'assez
d'assez à la fois intéressant surprenant
et est très dérangeant parce que ça veut
dire qu'au coeur même de la sphère
financière dans l'union européenne dans
la zone euro on a un acteur majeur qui
s'appelle deutsche bank qui est une des
grandes banques systémiques de la zone
euro qui trafiquent avec les oligarques
russes qui fait du blanchiment d'argent
sale depuis les années l'une des
conséquences de ceux ci par exemple et
ça je pense que c'est une révolution
intellectuelle dans la géopolitique
mondiale c'est le rôle de deutsche bank
dans le sauvetage financier de donald
trump au début les années 90 c'est
quelque chose qui a été montré par un
historien américain qui s'appelle
timothy sneijder qui est pro faiella et
qui a écrit un bouquin que je vous
recommande vraiment que j'ai lu il ya
deux ans qui s'appelle de gold to and
freedom
donc le chemin de la servitude
ou sneijder montre ce si au début les
années 90 trump été complètement défait
financièrement ce que vous savez que
c'est un très mauvais un businessman il
avait des dettes qui s'élevaient à
plusieurs millions ce qui pour un
individu commence à faire beaucoup et
était incapable de rembourser ses dettes
et il ya quelqu'un qui a remboursé qu'à
payer ses dettes pour lui ce quelqu'un
ce sont les oligarques russes avec la
médiation de deutsche bank tout ceci est
parfaitement documenté par sneijder est
donc la conséquence de ça c'est qu'il
est difficile aujourd'hui d'écarter
l'hypothèse que trump à son corps
défendant ou non peu importe peu importe
la question de la conscience le piloter
serait piloté par les oligarques russes
est donc maintenant si vous avez cette
clé de lecture quand vous sur poutine
alors oui alors la question c'est
derrière les oligarques russes
évidemment ya poutine ce que montre
sneijder c'est que poutine est un type
extrêmement dangereux dont l'idéologie
politique aujourd'hui est inspiré par un
gars qui s'appelle ivan aller semble
dovic ils viennent qui est le grand
idéologue fasciste russe des années 20
et qui est lui c'est lui qui a théorisé
l'idée du panslavisme militarisé russe
qui doit occuper la totalité de l'europe
c'est ça le disons l'arrière fond
idéologique de poutine il est né le seul
gars que site poutine de manière
récurrente dans ses discours publics et
c'est un type franchement non dont le
l'arrière-fond intellectuel politique
idéologique est vraiment trés trés
nauséabond ce qui me fait absolument pas
peur poutine et donc ça ça jette une
lumière assez intéressante sur disons la
stratégie politique de poutine qui rend
la chose assez compliqué c'est à dire je
pense que nous en france on est habitué
à penser le monde en termes de yab les
pros des pro atlantistes disons d'un
côté il ya les pro russe de l'autre est
en fait la situation aujourd'hui
beaucoup plus compliqué que ça gentil et
les antilles voilà exactement alors
c'est plus compliqué pourquoi parce que
d'un côté la russie au fond est une
puissance moyenne une petite population
150 millions d'habitants tous massés à
l'ouest de l'oural donc c'est un petit
pays fondamentalement la russie qui a
plus du tout la puissance dont a disposé
à l'époque de l'empiré soviétique dans
le même temps c'est le seul pays dont on
me dit quand j'ai discuté avec des
stratèges militaires
que il a une vraie stratégie au niveau
mondial qui articule à la fois la
propagande politique le hacking
informatique la stratégie militaire est
aujourd'hui par exemple au moyen-orient
ceux qui sont vraiment les maîtres du
jeu sont les rues se joue donc
l'occident a complètement perdu le
contrôle de ce qui se passe au
moyen-orient y compris maintenant de ce
qui se passe au liban à travers dix ans
la position extrêmement dur du hezbollah
donc de l'iran et donc in fine et de la
russie donc donc ça veut dire poutine
d'un côté est un type qui est inspiré
par une idéologie fasciste de prise de
contrôle sur l'europe il n'a évidemment
pas les moyens de cette politique
aujourd'hui donc qu'est-ce qui fait ce
qu'il fait c'est que il essaie de
contrôler son grand ennemi qui est
l'unique et les états unis en poussant
depuis une trentaine d'années un gars
complètement perdus qui s'appelle donald
trump qui est arrivé au pouvoir grâce à
la manipulation des élections d'il ya
quatre ans et qui va essayer de refaire
le coup en manipulant de nouveau les
élections avec la complicité de la
russie
le précédent non pas par à-coups obama
mais bush ouais j'avais aussi un petit
big mac avec les élections non la schl
au oui oui tout à fait c'est vrai donc
ce n'est pas la première fois que les
élections américaines sont probablement
trafiqués mais là disons il ya quelque
chose de beaucoup plus systématique à
travers disons le hacking russe sur les
réseaux sociaux la manipulation des
élections et la manipulation d'un type
de la john qui est tel que lorsque vous
y réfléchissez deux minutes pouvez vous
demander quelle est la décision qui a
été prise par trump depuis quatre ans
qu'ils soient vraiment défavorable aux
russes et depuis que j'ai 7 les lectures
je ne trouve pas je vois pas de décision
prise par les états unis par la maison
blanche qui soit fondamentalement
défavorable aux russes y compris leur
chemin exemple les sanctions dans
lesquelles vous avez là aussi non ça
c'est de la blague le retrait du cren le
retrait du moyen-orient tout ça c'est
absolument extrêmement bénéfique
extrêmement bénéfique pour la russie ça
ouvre le territoire la prise de pouvoir
russe ça veut pas dire qu'il faille
diaboliser poutine et qu'il faille par
exemple à mon avis pour la france
aujourd'hui pour sa souveraineté refuser
de dialoguer avec poutine c'est
certainement un interlocuteur
indispensable
la question c'est qu'il faut évidemment
dialoguer avec poutine de manière
pragmatique en étant parfaitement
conscient de sa propre stratégie
lui qui est d'un côté prendre le pouvoir
tout le moyen-orient et de l'autre
déstabiliser l'union européenne de
manière à semer le chaos chez nous donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle poutine
finances salvini en italie finances
marine le pen en france a soutenu
à bout de bras la stratégie du président
de boris johnson et c'est donc c'est ça
aujourd'hui alors on peut plus à mon
avis penser la géopolitique mondiale
depuis la france en termes complètement
simplice de atlantis d'un côté pro russe
de l'autre il faut penser à la fois des
états unis qui sont repartis manipulé
par la russie venez aussi dont l'intérêt
majeur aujourd'hui est de déstabiliser
l'union européenne parce qu'elle n'a pas
les moyens de faire plus et parce que ça
et peut y contribuer via par exemple la
manipulation des réseaux sociaux et le
soutien un certain nombre de partis
politiques qui veulent fondamentalement
en finir avec l'union européenne voilà
c'est ça qu'il faut réfléchir
aujourd'hui et ça veut dire qu'on à
repenser complètement la géo politique
française parce que je suis pas sûr du
tout que au quai d'orsay on est
complètement intégré cette nouvelle
donne
revenons revenons sur la russie les
etats-unis est-ce qu'il ya pas un
billard à trois bandes
face à la chine voyez pas ce qu'est ce
que la russie alors on va dire que les
états unis sont aussi manipulé par tout
un tas de réseau que ce choix l'arabie
saoudite qui détient 7 ou 8 % des bons
du trésor américain si mes chiffres sont
bons je demande à me faire façe qu'est
donc il ya aussi d'autres lobbys qui
font pression sur le gouvernement
américain et sur les intérêts américains
mais est ce que les états unis
finaux comme ils sont ne sont pas en
train de faire un billard à trois bandes
pour encadrer la chine ou avoir un
vecteur de communication plus
privilégient pour discuter avec la chine
vous voyez non c'est à dire ce serait
prêté beaucoup d'intelligence
stratégique aux états unis en
particulier l'administration américaine
dont je ne sais pas sur quelles soient
incapables aujourd'hui en tout cas sous
la direction de nstein ça me paraît pas
ça me paraît pas évident revenons juste
sur le jeu extrêmement complexe que je
joue là aussi avec la chine eux c'est
clair que la russie sait très bien
qu'elle est incapable de peser face à la
chine en particulier la socialiste le
gigantesque territoire sibérien qui a
qui est une ressource extraordinaire
pour les années qui viennent il est
clair que c'est beaucoup plus facile
pour la chine de l'occuper que pour
moscou qui est beaucoup trop loin mais
c'est le cas depuis des siècles en fait
depuis des siècles les empires russe
tsariste savent que l' empire chinois
est beaucoup plus proche
fondamentalement de la sibérie que que
moscou dans une certaine manière moscou
est obligé de composer en permanence
avec la avec la chine à la fois de
passer des alliances donc ils ont passé
des alliances énergétique extrêmement
importante c'est les grands accords
scellés premiers grands accords
commerciaux et énergétiques ne sont pas
libellés en dollars entre la russie la
chine et dans le même temps la russie
sait très bien que si elle se fait
écraser par la chine n existe plus que
donc elle est obligée de continuer à
jouer un jeu très ambiguë avec la chine
de je t'aime moi non plus voilà la rue
les états unis là dedans bon je n'ai pas
compris qu'une chose c'est que
l'autonomie à des états unis passent par
recouvrer sa souveraineté passé par un
protectionnisme commercial vis-à-vis
machine donc trump ne vous croient plus
du tout et il a raison sur ce sur ce
plan là ils ont au legend qui tourne
autour du libre commerce et du libre
échange même s'il n'a jamais étudié ces
questions évidemment fondamentalement il
ne comprend pas grand chose mais il a
compris intuitivement que le
protectionnisme est une voie de salut
pour les états unis aujourd'hui pour le
reste il détruit son administration
publique aujourd'hui donc on ne voit pas
bien au niveau des informations qu'on a
qui sont juste à la surface mais les
informations dont je dispose mois montre
que il a nommé des clowns qui lui
ressemble d'autres petites robes à toute
une série de postes clés de
l'administration fédérale américaine
qu'ils sont en train de détruire l'état
fédéral américain et ça va ça va prendre
des années aux états unis pour
reconstruire ça ça c'est tout bénéfice à
la fois pour la chine et pour la russie
qui sur ce plan là ont tous les deux un
intérêt objectif à déstabiliser et
affaiblir les états unis je vous entends
un peu aride avec nos amis du quai
d'orsay
pourquoi vous êtes si aride et vécu je
suis pareil avec eux je pense que ce que
j'essaie de dire ça si tu es concevoir
la stratégie et l'anticipation quand
même pour le kid ans et ça fait mal
c'est un cerf j'ai pas dit ça je pense
que le quai d'orsay notre cadence et
possède à la fois d'excellents
diplomates et en même temps mon avis est
l'héritier d'une vision du monde que
j'essaie d'écrire très rapidement entre
atlantis d'un côté pro russe de l'autre
qui n'est plus qui n'est plus de mise
aujourd'hui donc il ya une révision du
logiciel à mettre en oeuvre aujourd'hui
au quai d'orsay dont je me pose la
question je n'ai pas absolument certain
qu'elle a lieu en ce moment est ce que
c'est possible bien sûr que c'est
possible on a des ressources
intellectuelles en france pour faire ça
bien sûr est ce que le quai d'orsay
n'est pas si je peux me permettre le mot
quand grigny dans sa torpeur
dans l'immobilisme
lequel ans et vit une période difficile
c'est à dire il faut prendre conscience
du fait qu'elle est à l'intérieur de
l'état français il ya une guerre qui est
livrée par bercy le ministère l'économie
des finances depuis des années contre le
quai depuis plus d'une vingtaine
d'années qui a commencé notamment avec
la suppression par exemple du ministère
la coopération et le transfert des
attributs l'émissaire la coopération à
l'agencé française du développement où
j'ai travaillé qui aujourd'hui a tous
les attributs du ministère et donc ceci
a permis de vider en fait
le quai d'orsay d'une partie de ses
attributions ce qui fait qu'il ya un
certain nombre de pays aujourd'hui dans
l'est dans l'hémisphère sud où le
directeur de l'agencé française de
développement quelquefois compte
davantage que l'ambassadeur locales et
donc ceci fait que le quai d'orsay se
vit aujourd'hui comme puni pénalisé
négliger ostracisé méprisée dans
l'administration française parce que il
est en guerre intestine contre merci et
que c'est une guerre que bercy dans la
longue durée est en train de gagner
voilà donc je crois qu'il faut
comprendre ce à dire nos diplomates
n'ont plus la reconnaissance sociale
politique symbolique dont il jouissait
jusqu'à la fin des années 90 sont en
guerre contre l'hyper yom in imperio que
constitue bercy et sont en passe de
perdre cette guerre donc il ya un enjeu
aujourd'hui qui est de revaloriser la
fonction diplomatique qui est de
revaloriser la recherche intellectuelle
stratégique sur la géopolitique donne un
exemple simple face à la chine
lorsqu'emmanuel macron est allé rendre
visite à jean ping en janvier 2018 il
s'est vu exposer la grande vision
grandiose duché jean ping sur les routes
de la soie
derrière le discours et la rhétorique
sur la civilisation écologique chinoise
ce qui se cache derrière ceci simplement
une stratégie extrêmement pragmatique de
la part des chinois de constituer des
routes commerciales sur le long desquels
la chine va rapatrier un symptôme de
ressources minières dont elle a besoin
manière impérative pour son propre
équilibre intérieur et par ailleurs
essayer d'écouler un certain nombre de
une partie de censure plus industrielle
qu'elle n'arrive pas à faire absorber
par ces classes moyennes c'est tout il
n'est pas question à ma connaissance
pour la chine d'investir véritablement
par exemple en afrique pour construire
les infrastructures industrielles de
l'industrialisation de l'afrique de
demain je crois pas du tout à ça c'est
plutôt stade de foot et quelques
dispensaire qui
oui ça c'est négligeable l'enjeu
véritable de mon point de vue c'est le
rapatriement des ressources minières
dont la chine a besoin pour sa survie
propres lorsque l'équipe la délégation
présidentielle qui entourait macron
s'est vu exposer ce grand projet
grandiose de la route de la soie un
certain nombre des fonctionnaires qui
étaient là dedans ils sont venus me
raconter mon 10mai fait nous la france
qu'est ce qu'on avait à raconter enfin
par rapport à ça c'est quoi le contre et
six français face à la vision des routes
de la soie on n'a pas aujourd'hui et
donc ça ça signal ils ont un défaut de
réflexion stratégique de fond en france
sur la vision du monde qu'on est capable
de proposer comme alternative aux routes
de la soie et si le grand récit chinois
des routes de la soie n'a pas de contre
eux récit il va finir par s'imposer dans
les têtes dans les imaginations ce qui
est des gens en partie en train
d'arriver me semble-t-il dans un certain
nombre d' imaginaires des élites qui
discutent dans les salons parisiens
j'entends de plus en plus au fond nous
sommes tous chinois he
une bonne dictature et la chinoise s'est
pas si mal que ça voyez une espèce de
dison d'état d'esprit collaborationniste
qui est en train petit à petit d'émerger
qui me paraît extrêmement dangereux qui
est absolument contraire à la
souveraineté française qui à mon avis
est en train de grandir pourquoi parce
qu'il ya un vide en face du grand récit
des routes de la soie qui fait
qu'actuellement on n'est pas capable
d'articuler un contreur et si vous
parlez d élite avec un grand z c'est ça
c'est quoi les évite
ceux qui se prennent pour des élites
c'est à dire qu'ils tiennent aujourd'hui
le pouvoir la fois financier et
médiatique intellectuelle économique
voilà
donc vous savez qu'aujourd'hui la
société française est structuré en trois
tiers vous avez un tiers qui fait des
études supérieures généraliste vous avez
un tiers qui passe un bac pro ou
technique vous avez et puis généraliste
mais qui ne fait pas d'études
généralistes supérieur et puis vous avez
un dernier tiers qui n'a pas le bac en
france dont contrairement à ce que
croient les membres du premier tiers il
n'ya pas 80 % d'une classe d'âge
aujourd'hui qui passent le bac c'est pas
vrai
et donc le tiers entre guillemets
éduquer supérieur lui il a accès à tous
les pouvoirs économiques financiers
symbolique médiatique les médias
globalement ne parle que de lui et ne
parlent qu'à lui et donc d'une certaine
manière un tiers c'est beaucoup plus
qu'il ya deux générations
il ya deux générations quand sartre
disait on peut pas se permettre de
désespérer billancourt il était
parfaitement conscient du fait qu'il
appartenait à une petite minorité qui
faisait moins 10% de la population et il
était contraint le dimanche midi à table
un repas dominical de parler avec la
cousine gertrude ou le cousin albert qui
a pas fait d'études aujourd'hui le tiers
éduquer supérieur est suffisamment
nombreux pour pouvoir vivre dans une
espèce d'endogamie sociale complète
sécession oui dans une sécession donc
c'est la fille de varenne donc ce tir là
ne parle plus aux deux entretiens la
population française ne sais plus ce que
vivent les deux autres tiers est très
étonné lorsque les deux autres tiers
votre nom par exemple la constitution
européenne en 2005 ou bien on organise
des ronds points avec des gilets jaunes
pour protester contre le sort qui leur
est réservé par le gouvernement actuel
donc il ya une mécompréhension est en
fait une méconnaissance grandissante de
la base de ce tiers de ce que vivent les
deux premiers tiers des français
aujourd'hui ce manque de foncier aux
perceptions il est on peut le conflit on
peut on peut ici les les reconnecter
avec la réalité voyez bien sûr ça sera
grand coup de gilet jaune comment à
grands coups de gilet jaune alors à
grands coups de gilets jaunes dans
attention premièrement regardons ce qui
s'est passé avec les gilet jaune et
gilet jaune ont rendu possible quelque
chose comme la convention citoyenne sur
le changement climatique sans les gilet
jaune ça n'aurait pas eu lieu c'est pas
macron qui tout d'un coup c'est dit on
va faire cette convention la convention
citoyenne a été rendue possible grâce à
la pression d'un gilet jaune la
convention citoyenne de mon point de vue
c'est un véritable miracle démocratique
qui montre que vous tiré au hasard 150
citoyens 1 voulez vous leur permettez
vous leur donner les moyens de se former
convenablement pendant neuf mois il vous
pondent in fine et un programme de
transition écologique pour la france qui
est plus intelligente que ce que la
haute fonction publique française a
conçu depuis 20 ans
donc donc ça ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que les deux premiers tiers de la
france sont capables de parler au
premier tiers d'avoir des raisonnements
et des conclusions et des préconisations
normative politiques qui sont du même
niveau que ce qui est capable de
produire le premier tiers et donc en
réalité il ya un dialogue tout à fait
possible c'est une partie du disons un
certain nombre de membres du premier
tiers qui à l'image d'ailleurs du
président de république
vive un mépris très très profond pour
les deux premiers tiers des françaises
et des français et croit frank
fondamentalement que ses deux premiers
tiers sont incapables de leur parler et
que nous rien à leur dire donc c'est ce
fossé là qui est en train de grandir
aujourd'hui d'incompréhension et la
convention citoyenne et ce qu'ont fait
les gilets jaunes à mon avis montre
qu'on est tout à fait capable si on s'en
donne les moyens de combler ce fossé
encore faut-il concerne les moyens de ce
point de vue là je trouve que la
convention citoyenne montre une chose
c'est que les médias ne font pas leur
boulot dans notre pays parce que s'il
faisait véritablement leur travail la
qualité du débat qui a eu lieu au sein
la convention citoyenne on pourrait la
voir dans l'espace public en france
aujourd'hui et c'est parce qu'on a
malheureusement
versus jean paul fitoussi récemment et
nous a dit qu'ils vous acquis qui vous a
rencontré ou siècle est ce que c'est
vrai c'est pas vrai comme ça c'est pas
vrai du tout me suis jamais allé au
siècle des âmes été invité par le siècle
vous connaissez le siècle oui bien sûr
c'est quoi le siècle le sexe est une
réunion régulière je pense mensuelle ça
comment du premier tir ah oui
certainement des membres uniquement du
premier tiers qui ce cop d'entre eux
pour discuter des grands thèmes du
moment et en particulier des grandes
priorités que les rédactions en mai 2010
médias doivent donner dans les sujets
qui vont faire l'actualité dans les
semaines qui viennent donc c'est une
manière pour une petite minorité
de se dire à elle même c'est quoi les
priorités des sujets dont il faut parler
quels sont les sujets dont on ne doit
pas parler et qu'elles sont disons les
postures on pourrait dire en termes
d'opinion qu'il faut adopter sur un
certain nombre de sujets c'est quoi la
bien pensants sur un certain nombre de
sujets vous informations de quelqu'un
qui a été au siècle qui s'est pas
vraiment rendu compte pendant plusieurs
années de ce qui s'y trame est vraiment
et qui expose tu m'as dit mais en fait
j'ai été extrêmement naïf et j'ai été
d'une certaine manière on la caution
morale parce que c'était la personne qui
valait ça a été un grand un
haut-fonctionnaire un grand serviteur de
l'état mais qui en fait a servi de
consultant mal à la réunion du siècle
voilà et donc qui s'est rendu compte ex
post de ce qui se passait vraiment au
siècle et qui l'animé si j'avais su
j'aurais jamais accepté de participer à
ces réunions simplement tout se passait
à mots couverts de manière plus ou moins
scripté et puis à la table au moins je
siège et on ne me disait pas tout était
enfin voilà donc c'est ça qui se passe
au siècle aujourd'hui
vous avez dit que vous discutiez avec
des stratèges militaires ouais vous
discutez comment est-ce que c'est eux
qui vous contacter si vous voulez
rencontrer ou quelle est leur pose
qu'est-ce qu'ils font donc c'est moi qui
les contacte je vais voir la fois des
militaires qui sont actuellement à
l'état major à balard et puis je vais
voir et c'est au moins aussi intéressant
des jeunes retraités militaires vous
savez que lorsque vous êtes un officier
vous pouvez prendre votre retraite à 55
ans vous avez un certain nombre
d'officiers français qui vont faire leur
deuxième carrière après 55 ans en allant
travailler par exemple pour les grands
groupes industriels français dans les
pays du sud par exemple en afrique pour
constituer des milices privées qui vont
protéger par exemple des villages par
exemple du village total au nigeria et
ce sont ces milices privées qui protège
les expatriés français qui vont
travailler dans ces villages si vous
voyez un petit peu comment ça fonctionne
puisque je suis allé dans ces villages
et total évidemment pas le seul à avoir
ce type de dispositif ce sont des
enceintes
protégé par des murs de quatre ou cinq
mètres de haut avec des barbelés des
miradors des chiens des de la milice
privée de la protection à l'entrée qui
est capable de résister à une attaque
militaire de niveau maximal à
l'intérieur vous avez la piscine la
salle de concert la salle de cinéma le
restaurant de luxe deux courts de tennis
et on lave des voitures avec de l'eau
potable et à l'extérieur les gens n'ont
pas d'eau potable à boire lorsque les
expats vont travailler sur le site
d'exploitation ils sortent de ce petit
havre paradisiaque dans des bus
militarisé jeep à l'avant militarisé
l'avant à l'arrière on s'arrête pas aux
feux rouges talkie walkie tout est
chronométré pour être sûr qu'il n'y a
pas de détournement et c est le seul
contact que les exploitons avec la
population locale c'est de saluer
nigérian à travers la vitre du bus c'est
tout pour le reste il est content ni
rencontrent jamais et puis à l'intérieur
du petit arbre paradisiaque vous avez
dans le meilleur des cas la femme de
l'ex pattes qui est là qui passe ses
journées à la piscine avec la femme de
son collègue du collègue de son mari et
qui dépensent une partie du salaire de
son mari chez le psy parce que
évidemment ça la rend complètement
dingue au bout de quelques jeunes
quelques années la formation d'où pour
le psy parce que l'une d'entre elles m'a
raconté ça donc je suis allé en fait
pour tout vous dire je suis allé faire
une enquête au sud du nigeria dans le
delta du niger pour total et donc en
fête totale est conscient des
difficultés qu'ils rencontrent avec ce
type de dispositif total se disait donc
il y avait des cadres dirigeants de
total tout à fait ouverts et
intelligente qui m'ont dit voilà on
comprend pas ça fait des années qu'on
met des millions sur la table pour d'une
certaine manière achetez notre droit
d'opérer dans la société nigériane et
faire en sorte que les populations
nigériennes arrête de saboter les
pipelines
de faire sauter des bombes actionnées
sur nos exploitations et a
expliqué nous aidez nous à comprendre
pourquoi ça marche pas alors évidemment
voyez tant que vous êtes prisonnier du
petit village paradisiaques et que vous
ne pouvez pas rencontrer les gens
autrement qu'à travers la vitre voilà
vous pouvez absolument pas comprendre ce
qui se passe donc ce que j'ai fait avec
une amie qui s'appelle cécile en noir
c'est qu'on est allés nous se balader
dans les villages et enquêter dans les
villages on a fait des enquêtes
évidemment c'est assez dangereux puisque
les français là bas des blancs de
manière générale sont kidnappés très
très vite par des groupes qui ont très
bien compris que le kidnapping c'est une
opération extrêmement lucrative donc à
l'époque on y est et nous on a passé
trois semaines dans les villages il ya
eu des expats qui travaillait pour un
pétrolier néerlandais qui ont été
kidnappés et la rançon ça a été un
million de dollars par personne voilà en
quelques pays en quelques heures
évidemment rubis sur l'ongle par la
société pétrolière
donc nous ce qu'on a fait c'est que on
est on avait sonné en italie s'est
installé dans un hôtel n'y avait pas
l'électricité et vous donc les gens
n'imaginent pas qu'il puisse y avoir des
blancs on circulait dans une voiture
banalisée on n'allait jamais mangé au
même endroit deux jours de suite c'est
et puis on a été protégée en fait par
les paysans nigérians extrêmement en
fête sympa vis-à-vis de nous qui à un
moment on était en train de se balader
dans la forêt nous ont dit n'allez pas
plus loin que là bas il ya un camp de
rebelles si vous entrer là dedans ils
vont vous kidnappé donc on a été
relativement protégé par les nigérians
avec lesquels on travaille et je
commente était prêtre
oui j'étais au courant que j'étais prête
c'était aussi un moyen de signaler que
je vous rien sur le marché du kidnapping
parce que l'église est connu pour ne pas
payer les rançons donc assez souvent
j'ai mis un col romain pour signaler sa
si vous êtes un ravisseur sachez que je
ne vaux rien donc ne vous fatiguez pas
essayé de me kidnapper
voilà est ce qu'il s'est passé c'est
qu'au bout de trois semaines
des étudiants nigériens avec lesquels on
travaille et on travaille avec
l'université de port harcourt nous ont
dit écoutez là maintenant on est
angoissé on est stressé parce que il ya
les bad boys qui entourent l'hôtel où
vous vivez et on pense que vous avez une
heure pour partir et donc on est parti
et là on est allé se réfugier dans un
hôtel dans un village total pour
échapper aux ravisseurs mais on est
quand même là on a quand même réussi à
rester trois semaines
il ya comprendre ceci qui est
fondamental qui est que c'est ce qu'on a
dit finalement à une maladie rection
total tout ça c'était il ya une dizaine
d'années c'est que finalement le
mécanisme même par lequel total et c'est
entre guillemets d'acheter la paix
sociale au nigeria est responsable de la
violence pourquoi parce que supposer que
vous vouliez faire passer un pipe line
sur une robe russe bon en fait la
brousse à l'état naturel ça n'existe pas
vous avez toujours un village qui est
pas très loin et donc le territoire sur
lequel vous allez faire passer votre
palplanches appartient à quelqu'un et
donc si vous arrivez sur les terres qui
appartiennent à monsieur ou qui va par
exemple vous à les dédommager mais vous
allez dédommager avec des sommes qui
pour nous européens paraissent
complètement dérisoire mais qui pour eux
les nigérians sont les sommes colossales
et donc vous faites passer quelqu'un
dans un village du jour au lendemain
disons d'un état qui est pas très très
éloignées malheureusement de l'âge de
pierre en termes technologiques à dix
ont une puissance monétaire qui est
extraordinaire pour lui c'est une manne
inouïe du jour au lendemain un monsieur
qui va s'en va quitte le village
abandonne sa femme ses enfants et va se
refaire une vie à des gosses par exemple
avec les moyens financiers dont il
dispose qui sont inouïe et puis son
voisin ou qui vaut qui est son copain de
toujours avec il était à l'école dont
les parents ont connu n'est pas en haut
qui aura etc depuis des générations lui
son lopin de terre est juste 5 mètres à
côté de l'endroit où passe le prix plein
donc lui n'a rien ok monsieur ou qui
vont lui vit avec sa femme ils
paraissent et le nul du village quoi
donc sa seule issue pour lui c'est de
faire semblant d'avoir aussi touché la
manne il part aussi à les gosses mais il
atterrit à les gosses dans les
bidonvilles là qui sont construits c'est
débile envie de da q str qui sont
construits sur le lac qui sert de
dépotoir aux eaux usées dans lesquels il
ya une odeur pestilentielle qui règne en
permanence toute l'année et il n'ose pas
dire à sa femme que lui en fait c'est un
pauvre des pauvres qui vit dans le slam
de négoce oui et donc ça ça détruit de
lien social dans les villages nigérien
parce que dans les villages il reste qu'
il reste plus que les personnes âgées
les femmes les invalides et les enfants
et donc avec ça vous plaît pas vous
pouvez pas vivre donc par exemple pense
que quelqu'un était désigné comme chef
d'un village aujourd'hui dans ces
régions là il doit signer un papier dans
lequel il s'engage vis à vis de sa
propre communauté à rester au village
s'il devient le chef du village pourquoi
parce que vous avez un certain nombre de
chefs du village qui ont compris qu'ils
pouvaient aller négocier leur posture de
chef la chefferie traditionnelle auprès
des pétroliers en disant écoutez voilà
moi maintenant je suis le chef de thé le
village pas loin donné le gars soit vous
me donnez de l'argent soit en fait vos
papilles vont sauter le matin parce que
je vais lâcher ma population sur vos
paul klein donc vous voyez évidemment
pétroliers puisque c'est beaucoup plus
simple j'ai de l'argent pour avoir la
paix et donc le gars s'en fout du
village et va essayer de mener la belle
vie à des gosses dont vous voyez la
déstructuration du lien social est
extrêmement puissante et en fait est
induite elle-même par là d'une certaine
manière la bonne volonté du pétrolier
qui veut juste pouvoir continuer
d'opérer tranquillement sur le
territoire et qu'il se rend pas compte
parce qu'il a perdu tout contact avec la
population que plus il le fait plus il
est ruiné un social plus il y aura la
violence exercée y compris contre lui
revenons à d'autres banques nouvelle
muse banques systémiques elles vont
comme en ce moment est ce qu'elles
peuvent encaisser un nouveau choc koji
des cieux les 1300 milliards des banques
centrales européennes
à taux négatifs qui arrose d'une façon
grand prince qui arrange tout le monde
est ce que vous êtes inquiet est ce qu
est ce que tu es inquiet par rapport aux
côtés systémique et quelles peuvent être
les répercussions d'un effet domino
est-ce que ça crée un chaos est ce que
ça crée une déstabilisation politique
est-ce que ça livre les populations
quatre vents de la propagande extérieur
est ce que ça va
quelles conséquences ça peut avoir alors
nos banques vont mal globalement aux
sanctions lesquelles donc les banques
françaises les banques allemandes les
banques italiennes donc les plus
fragiles c'est les banques italiennes ya
aucun doute donc france elle c'est pour
voir les quatre banques systémiques bnp
société générale bpce natixis
lcl est allé à l'école les plus fragiles
c'est lequel alors j'ai pas de
l'information très récente mais je pense
que la plus fragile c'est que derrick
hall mais ce serait quelque chose qu'il
faudra vérifier aujourd'hui ça fait un
petit moment que j'ai pas vérifié le
bilan de ces banques est aujourd'hui
la raison fondamentale de leur fragilité
aujourd'hui c'est que n ont toujours pas
de nettoyer leurs bilans des est ce
qu'on appelle les mpr d'énormes
performing loans dont elles ont hérité
de la crise de subprimes de 2008 le fmi
de christine lagarde l'a dit pendant des
années il ya plus de 300 milliards de
yens pièce qui traînent dans les bilans
des banques européennes et elles n'ont
toujours pas fait le travail pourquoi
parce qu'elle voit pas l'intérêt de le
faire et elle continue grâce à la manne
monétaire incroyable de la bce de
d'utiliser cet argent pour faire des
opérations à fort effet de levier sur
les marchés financiers donc premièrement
ils sont très fragiles contrairement à
ce qu'on raconte
deuxièmement elles sont sous
capitalisées ce que le fmi a également
dénoncé depuis des années ce que j'ai
expliqué dans un rapport que jérémy au
parlement européen en 2015 montrant que
si on avait une réédition de la crise
des subprimes de 2008 la moitié nos
banques sont en faillite pourquoi parce
que en 2008 par exemple vous avez un
certain nombre de banques qui ont essuyé
des pertes de valeur de leurs actifs de
11 % disposent pour ça or la
capitalisation nos banques aujourd'hui
ces trois pour ça donc c'est juste très
simple c'est de l'arithmétique
élémentaire si nos banques essuient un
cataclysme de même envergure que celui
2008 une partie d'entre elles sera en
faillite demain matin alors évidemment
la bce va tout faire pour éviter que ça
arrive et va essayer de faire en sorte
en particulier que la crise de
solvabilité qui aujourd'hui disons à la
porte un certain nombre de nos banques
qui est induite par quoi qui est induite
fondamentalement par la déflation dont
enfin les autorités publiques françaises
continuent commence aujourd'hui à
reconnaître l'existence et la réalité je
vais revenir ce que c'est que la
déflation la bce va tout faire pour que
la crise de solvabilité fondamental de
nos banques ne se traduisent pas en une
crise de liquidités on va continuer
d'arroser un coût de 1000 milliards à
mon avis nos banques de manière qu'elle
ne fasse pas faillite a pour objectif un
taux négatif donc ça veut dire que nos
banques sont payés par la bce pour
emprunter à la bce au passage je vois
une parenthèse c'est ça qui explique le
fait que nos banques sont très très
friands de passer à la monnaie
électronique sais pas si vous avez
repéré cette affaire
c'est que je reviendrai sur la déflation
que c'est un sujet important pourquoi
est-ce que donc aujourd'hui on vous dit
mais les billets les billets de banque
et la monnaie scripturale ces vieux jeu
c'est médiévale il faut passer
uniquement il faut régler toutes vos
transactions monétaires par la banque
par laquelle le crédit bancaire et
uniquement les opérations d'écriture
numérique la raison de ce si c'est la
situation très paradoxale dans laquelle
du sort d'aujourd'hui qui est que nos
banques donc se font payer par la bce
pour emprunter à la bce
premièrement évidemment elle reporte pas
ça du tout sur leur clientèle qu'elle
paye pas le client pour que les clients
leur empreinte
et dont elles se font des marges
colossales puisqu'elles sont payés pour
emprunter avec de l'argent qu'elles vont
qui vont leur permettre de créer de la
monnaie pour prêter à leurs clients un
taux positif ça te fait spécialement
ondes ils se font des couilles nous on
pourrait dire ça d'un autre côté est
symétriquement en miroir nos banques
parce qu'elles savent qu'elles sont
assez peu fiable vont mettre beaucoup
d'argent en dépôt à la bce dans le mille
en dab est ce pour ça normalement elle
devrait être rémunéré par la bce mais
comme la bce précisément les payent pour
leur emprunter la bce très logiquement
parce que ça équilibre de son bilan en
dépend demande aux banques de payer pour
avoir le droit de mettre en dépôt de
l'argent à la bce donc c'est le monde à
l'envers c'est en fait elles mettent en
dépôt et doivent payer empreinte doivent
elles sont payés pour ça mais du coup ça
ça déplaît aux banques elles sont très
contentes d'être payé pour pouvoir
emprunter en revanche elle se paye tout
contente de devoir payer pour mettre de
l'argent en dépôt à la bce du coup
l'idée géniale qui leur est venue c'est
de dire on va faire payer par nos
clients le coût que ça nous coûte à nous
de mettre de l'argent en dépôt à la bce
et comment on va faire on va faire payer
nos clients sur les comptes de dépôts de
nos clients chez nous donc ça veut dire
que vous lorsque vous recevez votre
salaire le 25 du mois si vous êtes
salarié le 26 la banque va pouvoir vous
dire écoutez voilà vous avez quand même
de la chance de pouvoir mettre votre
argent en dépôt chez moi je vais vous
prélevez une petite somme qui était au
début évidemment va l'être
infinitésimale pour éviter que vous
souffriez tron
parce que simplement parce que vous avez
la grâce de pouvoir mettre votre argent
en dépôt chez moi
si vous faites que les sommes
infinitésimale c'est pas très
intéressant mais si vous commencez à
augmenter le taux de prélèvement un
certain nombre d'entre nous vont réagir
comment à votants par leurs pieds et en
retirant l'argent de leur compte
bancaire et en mettant cet argent sous
leur matelas sauf que si vous n'avez
plus de monnaie scripturaire si vous
pouvez plus retirer les billets du
guichet de banque pouvait plus faire ça
vous êtes pieds poings liés devant la
banque parce que vous ne pouvez pas
cacher dans votre matelas des lignes de
codes informatiques c'est juste
impossible et donc la monnaie
électronique est un moyen ensuite de
pouvoir prélever de l'argent sur les
comptes en banque des déposants français
sans qu'ils aient des moyens de retirer
leur argent de leur compte bancaire
évidemment vous avez bien oui mais si
une banque fait ça moi je retire mon
argent électroniquement et je vais les
mettre sur le compte je vais aller
ouvrir un compte dans une autre banque
sauf qu'évidemment elles vont tout le
faire en même temps parce qu'elles vont
se coordonner
comment mais bien poste oui alors
évidemment il reste la pause mais la
poste va se coordonner avec les autres
grandes banques qui vont lui mettre la
pression pour qu'elle en fasse autant de
sorte qu'on aura pas d'échappatoire oui
donc c'est ça qui est visé est donc
derrière la rhétorique de l'hyper
modernité des grands vents de l'avenir
etc et de la monnaie scripturale qu'il
monnaie médiévale en les tests et
derrière c'est la capacité que les
banques veulent se donner elle même de
tondre la laine sur le dos des français
sans qu'ils aient les moyens de se
protéger contre les banques c'est ça qui
est derrière je reviens un instant sur
la question la déflation parce que c'est
important la déflation c'est beaucoup
plus grave que l'inflation la déflation
c'est un mal qui a saisi l'europe les
états unis dans les années 30 et donc
les états unis ne s'en sortis que grâce
à la seconde guerre mondiale
les symptômes de la déflation c'est plus
d'inflation ce qui est le cas en europe
de l'ouest depuis en france en
particulier depuis 2004 safé 2015 ça
fait cinq ans maintenant que la banque
de france échoue à remplir sa mission
qui est de maintenir un taux d'inflation
proche de + 2 % par an elle n'y arrive
plus du tout deuxième symptôme plus de
croissance troisième symptôme des dettes
privées très élevé donc je redis ce que
j'ai déjà dit dans beaucoup dans sainte
que le problème de la zone euro
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas la dette
publique mais c'est la dette privée on a
beaucoup trop de dettes privées et à
l'issue du confinement la dette publique
française a augmenté on n'est pas on va
passer de 99 % du pib dette publique a
probablement 120 peut-être 125% du pib
de dette publique mais du côté de la
dette privée c'est bien plus grave avant
le confinement on était à 130 pour 100 g
pas les chiffres sur ce que ça peut être
à l'issue du confinement mais ce sera
très probablement au moins dû 150% et de
ce point de vue là le plan de relance
français ne va pas améliorer les choses
parce qu'une bonne partie du plan de
relance français c'est de la dette c'est
du prêt accordé par l'état français aux
entreprises dont la dette va continuer
d'augmenter donc premiers symptômes plus
d'inflation deuxième symptôme pas de
croissance troisième symptôme beaucoup
de dettes privées beaucoup trop 4e alors
pourquoi est-ce que c'est problématique
c'est que si vous avez trop de dettes
privées vous pouvez plus investir parce
que si vous êtes une entreprise où ils
peuvent vous pouvez pas les voir votre
banquier en lui disant m'a écouté j'ai
besoin d'emprunter pour financer mon
investissement parce que votre banquier
va vous dire d'accord vous êtes gentil
mais payé d'avoir votre dette et puis si
vous êtes un ménage vous pouvez pas
aller voir votre banquier en lisant je
voudrais acheter un nouvel appartement
donc je vais emprunter puisque votre
banquier va vous dire de nouveau vous
êtes gentil mais commencer par payez
votre dette donc donc trop de trop de
dettes privées et puis quatrième
symptômes extrêmement grave un
affaissement progressif de ce qu'on
appelle la vitesse de circulation de la
monnaie c'est-à-dire du nombre de fois
qu'un euros changent de main dans une
année donc la vitesse de circulation de
la monnaie elle et elle est comprise en
gros entre eux ils ont 3 et 10 pour les
nations industrialisées depuis une
trentaine d'années
et en france elle et elle est passée de
5 au début des années 2000 à moins de 3
aujourd'hui donc elle est en train de
baisser et ça c'est le quatrième
symptômes qui fait que à mon avis si on
ne réagit pas aujourd'hui la zone euro
est en train de s'enfoncer dans un
scénario à la japonaise donc dans une
japonisation d'europe qui est telle que
si on entre si on tente dans la trappe à
liquidité je ne sais pas comment on
dansa le japon shinzo abe patauge dans
la déflation depuis 30 ans et même
quelqu'un d'aussi volontariste et
autoritaire que shinzo abe n'ai pas
réussi à sortir n'a pas réussi à sortir
l'économie japonaise de ce piège alors
jusqu'à il ya disons un an les autorités
publiques françaises étaient dans la
dénégation par exemple le gouverneur de
la banque de france
expliqué à qui voulait l'entendre que la
déflation ça n'existe pas en tout cas
pas en france
aujourd'hui heureusement ils commencent
à changer la tonalité du discours et
reconnaître que c'est un véritable
risque est à mon avis ça veut dire qu'il
faut arrêter de faire simplement des
prêts et il faut mettre en place des
politiques monétaires beaucoup plus
agressive et des politiques bodji
budgétaire également beaucoup plus
agressive pour sortir la france de la
trappe qu'est ce que ça veut dire dans
la vie la vraie solution dans cette
affaire et en faisant ça on fait d'une
pierre 15 coûts c'est un plan de
reconstruction écologique de l'économie
française financée par de la dette
financée par la création monétaire
qu'est ce que c'est que cette affaire
c'est si on veut que l'économie
française soit résiliente à l'impact du
dérèglement climatique dans les années
qui viennent et contrairement à ce que
croient certains aujourd'hui la france
ne sera pas du tout épargné par l'impact
du dérèglement climatique et la montée
du niveau de la mer on a des scénarios
maintenant de plus de mettre à la fin du
siècle ça veut dire une destruction
d'une bonne partie du littoral français
je discutais encore ya pas très
longtemps avec un vélo treuil qui me
disent donc grands climatologues
français qui me disait d'ici 2050 donc
c'est juste après demain d'ici 2050 la
banlieue de montpellier sera les pieds
dans l'eau
oui la cam va disparaître petit à enfin
se dire c'est une transformation de
salinisation des sols tout à fait et
donc c'est une transformation drastique
à la foi de la géographie l'économie
française qui nous attend dans les
années qui viennent donc si on veut
éviter ça il faut un plan de
reconstruction écologique du pays qui
coûte de l'argent mais qu'il ne faut pas
financée par de la dette qu'il faut
financer par la création monétaire ou
bien interactive très intéressante à mon
avis mais qui revient à peu près au même
pas l'annulation de la dette publique au
bilan de la banque centrale européenne
donc j'ai dit peut-être un mot là-dessus
parce que ça a été extrêmement polémique
depuis quelques mois disons qu'on m'a
accusé de promouvoir delà de l'économie
vaudou voilà qui boit des gens qui en
urgence visa ni ferry agnès bénassy
quéré la nouvelle chef économiste du
trésor donc l'idée est la suivante la
banque centrale européenne depuis
au-moins 2009 est en fait de manière
systématique depuis 2015 rachète des
titres d'aidés publiques auprès des
banques privées donc comment ça se passe
vous avez une adjudication du trésor
l'état émet de la dette publique une
banque par exemple bnp paribas achètent
ces deux titres de dette publique et les
tea trees c'est à dire les transforme en
un actif financier qu'on peut échanger
sur les marchés financiers et les revend
immédiatement la banque centrale
européenne pourquoi parce que la bce
s'est engagée à le faire moyennant une
petite commission
de sorte que la bce possède à son bilan
aujourd'hui
l'équivalent de 2200 milliards d'euros
de dette publique de pays de la zone
euro et pour la france 420 milliards
donc c'est pas des petites sommes
donc ma proposition mais c'est la
proposition qui est défendu par
l'institut rousseau nicolas dufresne
alain grandjean a pris position en
faveur de cette idée là
jézabel couppey soubeyran laurentia
l'homme et c'est notre proposition c'est
de dire écoutez la seule banque qui peut
aujourd'hui
accusé le coup de faire des grosses
pertes sur son bilan c'est la banque
centrale européenne ce sont les banques
centrales tout simplement parce qu'une
banque centrale peut créer de la monnaie
pour se recapitaliser elle même ce
qu'une banque de second rang une banque
privée ne peut pas fait donc ce n est qu
une banque privée crée de la monnaie
tous les jours quand elle accorde un
crédit elles créent la monnaie en
revanche elle est obligée de créer de la
monnaie statutairement pour un client
extérieur à elle même elle peut pas
créer de la monnaie pour se sauver
elle-même ne peut pas être à elle-même
son propre qui a un prix mais elle peut
pas imprimer pour se sauver c'est la
raison pour laquelle et des banques qui
font faillite monte dei paschi di siena
en revanche la banque centrale elle peut
le faire et donc il ya un rapport de la
berri la banque des règlements
internationaux qu'est la banque centrale
des banques centrales à ban ki
réexplique à ceux qui auraient pas
compris qu'une banque centrale a le
droit de créer de la monnaie pour se
recapitaliser elle même autrement dit le
scénario est le suivant aujourd'hui la
bce à 2200 milliards de dettes publiques
de la zone euro dans son bilan elle
accepte l'annulation de cette dette donc
le non remboursement de cette dette elle
fait une perte de 1200 milliards
aujourd'hui ses fonds propres ces 10
milliards donc donc si les knicks ne
tient rien du tout donc il faut pas
croire une demi-seconde que la stabilité
et la fiabilité de leurs aux dépens des
fonds propres de la bce pour une zone
dont le pic de 14 mille milliards c'est
pas les 10 milliards de la fonds propres
de la bce qui garantissent la fiabilité
l'euro elle fait une perdue de 1200
milliards sur son bilan donc
elle a aidé à des fonds propres qui font
2104 moins de 1100 90 milliards de
d'euros qu'est ce qu'elle fait elle crée
c'est une pure opération d'écriture qui
nous coûte rien à personne 0 à qui que
ce soit elle crée la quantité qui va
bien pour se recapitaliser elle même est
de nouveau avoir aimé ton 10 milliards
d'euros de fonds propres
le couple question d'internet de malines
gaël giraud pourriez vous s'il vous
plaît qualifier votre position
concernant l'annulation de la dette des
états cela ne revient-il pas à donner
quitus à tous ceux qui ont bénéficié de
cette pyramide depuis 40 ans affiché à
figer leurs privilèges sans jamais
qu'ils aient à rembourser
je comprends cette question c'est une
fausse donc je vais m'expliquer là
dessus et
je la termine un peu pour toujours de
amine quid des gens qui ont travaillé
dur payer leurs impôts et rembourser
leurs crédits quid de l'équité entre les
bénéficiaires de cette dette et les gens
ordinaires qui ont une vie simple alors
que ce système est alors hors de ce
système pardon en un mot à qui profite
vraiment l'annulation de la dette bon
c'était comme une excuse à une très
bonne question à la gsl expliqué un
petit peu ça il faut comprendre
effectivement que 1 il y a
comment dire ça vous et moi qui ne
sommes pas des banquiers lorsque nous
empruntons de la monnaie nous sommes
obligés de trimer dur pour la rembourser
pourquoi parce qu'il faut rembourser le
capital il faut rembourser en plus les
intérêts de l'emprunt et donc il faut
qu'on commence on rembourse d'abord les
grands seront pas remboursés des
intéressés mais ça veut dire que in fine
et il faut produire plus de valeur que
ce qu'on a emprunté auprès du banquier
puisqu'on doit ont dû rembourser
davantage que ce qu'on lire emprunté et
c'est là que toute la question de cette
personne est tout à fait légitime s'il
ya des gens qui bossent pas le premier
vous aussi tout le monde qui bossent dur
pour voir rembourser des emprunts
pour les banques les choses ne sont pas
du tout du même ordre parce qu'une
banque peut créer de la monnaie ex
nihilo et ça lui coûte rien et donc la
grande différence c'est que lorsqu'une
banque elle même empreinte et les
banques empruntent tous les jours
c'est pas du tout la même chose que pour
alain particulier qui lui doit
travailler dur pour rembourser une
banque alors donc je réexplique un tout
petit peu le système monétaire dans un
pays comme la france il est construit à
deux niveaux imaginez vous avez le mont
olympe
ans rue du moulin vous avez zeus the
c'est la bce et puis en bas du mont
olympe vous avez les dieux les dieux ce
sont les banques et puis vous avez le
reste de la plaine de la grèce antique
ça c'est vous et moi avec la sexy c'est
ça voilà par exemple alors les dieux et
the skies le dieu des dieux
échangent entre eux avec une monnaie que
ni vous ni moi n'avons jamais vu que ça
paie la monnaie banque centrale cette
monnaie n'arrive jamais dans l'économie
réelle donc là n'arrivera jamais dans
votre poche n'arriverait jamais dans
votre compte bancaire elle est piégée
dans ce qu'on appelle le marché
interbancaire et elle sert à réguler les
transactions entre les banques et avec
la banque centrale européenne donc
lorsqu'on dit la banque centrale
européenne imprime des milliers de
milliards fait c'est d'argent en monnaie
banque centrale que crée la banque
centrale européenne ça lui coûte rien
c'est une pure opération d'écriture font
un peu d'électricité pour faire
fonctionner d'ordinateurs et qu'il faut
payer quelqu'un qui tape sur un clavier
mais c'est tout
cet argent-là autorise les banques donc
les dieux du mont olympe a discuté avec
les humbles mortels que nous sommes qui
nous n'avons pas le pouvoir de création
monétaire via par exemple de la création
monétaire pour accorder un crédit donc
lorsque je vais voir mon banquier et que
je lui demande un emprunt pour acheter
par exemple un appartement et qui est ce
qui fait que je vais devoir bosser dur
toute ma vie pour rembourser mon emprunt
le banquier qu'est-ce qui fait il va pas
voir dans les sous-sols de la banque
s'il a suffisamment de des billets de
banque pour me prêter il va regarder si
je suis solvables et si c'est
intéressant pour lui de créer de la
monnaie ex nihilo pour moi ça lui coûte
rien et s'il me dit non les innombrables
aux dames je peux pas vous prêtez pas ce
que vous savez les temps sont durs la
monnaie on ne trouve pas sa soupe à la
tomate c'est en fait il me raconte des
salades tout ce qu'il veut me dire c'est
qu'il veut pas me prêter parce que je ne
fais pas un client intéressant pour lui
soit qu'ils estiment que je ne sois pas
solvable soit qu'ils estiment que pour
jeu soit solvable il va être obligé de
me prêter un taux d'intérêt qui
n'intéresse pas
ceux ci est un secret bien gardé c'est à
dire que j'ai donné pas mal de
conférences grand public lorsque
j'explique ça au grand public des gens
comprennent qu'en réalité leur banquier
peut créer de la monnaie ex nihilo
demain matin et donc regarde leur leur
banquier avec un tout autre regard que
celui qu'ils avaient précédemment c'est
une espèce de mythe qui est entretenue
savamment dans l'opinion publique qui
est que les banques ne sont pas des
banques les banques sont des
intermédiaires financiers qui vous prêt
de la main gauche quelle empreinte de la
main droite c'est pas vrai c'est comme
ça que c'est formalisé dans les modèles
standards des économistes il n'y a pas
de banque où il n'y a que des
intermédiaires financiers qui est près
de la main gauche ce qu'ils empruntent
de la main droite une banque ça
fonctionne pas du tout comme ça une
banque c'est un une institution
financière qui a reçu du roi le droit
régalien de frapper monnaie et donc il
peut créer de la monnaie
alors une fois qu'on a compris ça puis
droit et commandées avec les roues c'est
sa part qu'on a pu droits et qu'on est
maintenant avec le roux voilà exactement
le traité de maastricht qu'est ce qu'il
a fait c'est qu'il a supprimé des mains
de l'état le pouvoir de création
monétaire qui était le droit régalien de
frapper monnaie pour le confier de
manière exclusive à la banque centrale
européenne du côté public donc du côté
de la sphère publique il reste plus
qu'un seul acteur qui a droit de frapper
monnaie c'est la bce qui est réputée
indépendante à l'égard des états et puis
du côté la sphère privée il reste plus
que les banques privées qui peuvent
créer des monnaies de sorte que les
citoyens vous et moi on a été exproprié
du pouvoir souverain de contrôle de la
monnaie raison pour laquelle par exemple
on voit dans la société civile
l'émergence de toute une série de
monnaies complémentaires des monnaies
locales dans la creuse par exemple il ya
des monnaies locales qui apparaissent et
ça ça devrait pas guéri à guéret
exactement ça ça traduit quoi ça traduit
la nécessité pour les communautés
locales de se réapproprier le pouvoir
monétaire et donc de créer des monnaies
locales qui vont pouvoir faire
développer et faire prospérer pour les
usages dont ils ont besoin aujourd'hui
et par exemple en grèce au moment de
l'explosion de la crise grecque entre
2010 et 2015 vous avez eu une explosion
du nombre de monnaies locales en grèce
parce que les gens n'avaient plus
d'accès à l'euro l'hérault était devenu
une monnaie rare et donc qui crée des
monnaies locales pour réussir à s'en
sortir et continuer à avoir des
transactions marchandes alors maintenant
dans le mécanisme qui s'est mis en place
à partir de manière systématique à
partir de 2015 mais qui avait déjà
débuté précédemment que se passe-t-il
lorsque l'état émet un titre de dette
publique dont il emprunte pour financer
des écoles à guéret la poste à la
souterraine et le service public à
besançon à besançon vieille ville
espagnole
qu'est-ce qui fait l'état et donc il
émet un titre ce titre aujourd'hui est
racheté par les banques ça c'est normal
puisque l'état n'a plus le droit au
moins depuis 1973 75 manière
systématique depuis le traité de
maastricht d'emprunter directement
auprès des banques centrales de sa
banque centrale jusque dans les années
soixante dix on a reconstruit comme la
france en une génération grâce au
circuit de bloch lainé qui consistait en
ce cycle trésor d'emprunter directement
à la banque de france à taux nul et en
fait non remboursés jamais sa dette ce
que la dette était rouler c'est à dire
que à chaque fois que le trésor devait
rembourser la banque de france et
réemprunter la banque de france la somme
qu'il lui devait et donc il roulait à
perpétuité la dette publique ce qui a
permis de reconstruire la france en une
génération ce système qui a très bien
fonctionné donner les coudées franches à
l'état pour avoir une vision stratégique
lancé les grands projets le projet
nucléaire français le tgv ariane etc ces
grands projets éoliens en fait ont été
financés grâce à ce système là
aujourd'hui l'état français ne peut plus
mettre en oeuvre ce type de projet parce
qu'il a été consulté par une idéologie
post libérale qui veut réduire
complètement le pouvoir de manoeuvre de
l'état en faveur du secteur privé et
imposer la discipline de l'austérité
budgétaire à l'état via le fait que
l'état aujourd'hui est obligé
d'emprunter sur les marchés financiers
et donc de se plier aux desiderata des
marchés financiers pour avant le droit
d'emprunter à taux nul aujourd'hui sur
le sur la dette française il ya 60% de
la dette française qui provient
uniquement de l'accumulation des taux
d'intérêt donc si on avait maintenu le
système de bloch lainé on aurait
uniquement 40% la dette française
aujourd'hui donc c'est considérable
alors donc le système qui a été mis en
place depuis 2015 c'est que l'état émet
un titre de dette publique qui est
acheté par une banque au moment où la
banque achète ce titre d'aidés publiques
elles prêtent à l'état français en
créant de la monnaie
ça ne coûte rien à la banque de faire ça
c'est une pure opération d'écriture donc
il ya aucun ouvrier français qui a bossé
dur pendant quarante ans pour que l'état
puisse se financer c'est ça qui n'a peur
de comprendre et c'est là que la
personne qui pose la question doit
entendre ça c'est à dire que le
financement de la dette publique
française ne se fait pas en faisant
primer un ouvrier ça se fait via le
pouvoir de création monétaire des
banques privées
lorsque la banque ayant créer de la
monnaie pour acheter le titre de dell
public français revendre ce titre
d'aidés publiques à la baisse' yeux la
bce à son tour créer de la monnaie mais
cette fois ci elles créent la monnaie
banque centrale qui est dans la partie
supérieure du mont olympe
d'accord cette monnaie banque centrale
ne va jamais atterrir dans l'économie
réelle ne va jamais alimenté l'inflation
et permet simplement de régler la
transaction entre la bce et la banque
admettons bnp paribas au moment où la
bce rachète ce titre d'aidés publiques
qu'est ce qu'elle fait en fait elle paye
la dette donc la dette de l'état
français en réalité en vérité elle a
déjà été payée par la bce au moment même
où la bce a racheté le titre de dell
public français auprès de bnp paribas
donc cette dette elle a été payée par
par la bce comment grâce au pouvoir de
création monétaire de la bce donc d'une
certaine manière aujourd'hui le
créancier sur l'état français c'est la
bce puisque la bce a racheté cette dette
en la payant il est bien évident que si
bnp paribas pouvait espérer gagner
davantage par le remboursement de la
dette publique par l'état français que
en vendant ce titre à l'habituel
vendrait pas la bce donc en fait le prix
auquel la bce rachète à la bnp paribas
couvrent largement ce que bnp paribas
pouvait espérer gagner du remboursement
de la dette par l'état français dans la
constitution américaine ils ont la
capacité de répudier leur dette mais
est-ce que vous pensez que les états
unis vont répudier landais non ça c'est
une toute autre affaire alors
alors premièrement un état peut très
bien répudier sa dette
il ya des
défauts souverains il y en a tous les
quatre ans en moyenne c'est pas la
première fois c'est certainement pas la
dernière l'argentine est en train de
faire défaut sur sa dette le liban va
probablement faire défaut sur sa dette
et ses conséquences a alors la
conséquence majeure c'est que c'est le
secteur privé qui a pénalisé c'est à
dire que si vous avez un certain nombre
de créanciers privés
c'est eux qui font la perte et c'est ce
qu'on a organisées par exemple en 2012
pour la dette publique grecque où on a
organisé une négociation entre les
créanciers privés de la grèce et athènes
de manière à faire ce qu'on appelle un
haircut c'est-à-dire une restructuration
de la dette publique grecque en 2012 qui
a été beaucoup plus compliqué est
beaucoup plus douloureuse que ce que je
suis en train de proposer sur
l'annulation de la dette publique
française au bilan de la bce pourquoi
parce que ce sont des banques privées et
les créanciers privés par exemple des
fonds de gestion d'actifs qui font la
perte or ils ont tous emprunter à des
taux différents à des maturités
différentes des quantités différentes et
donc il faut harmoniser tout ça et c'est
un calcul bien compliqué pour savoir
pour faire ce travail là de manière
relativement équitable entre les
différents créanciers d'un état ce que
je suis en train de proposer au niveau
de la bce c'est beaucoup beaucoup plus
simple et c'est beaucoup moins
douloureux ça ne coûte rien à personne
qu'est ce que vous entendez par
douloureux pas douloureux au sens où
c'est là que disons la métaphore qui est
pas une métaphore d'ailleurs de la
personne qui posait la question tout à
l'heure sur l'ouvrier qui a trimé dur
toute sa vie pour pouvoir rembourser des
dettes intervient c'est à dire que
lorsque c'est le secteur privé qui qui
fait la perte ça veut dire qu'il ya un
actionnaire par exemple de l'ère du
secteur privé qui fait la perte et qui
perd de l'argent donc il ya un citoyen
qui perd de l'argent concrètement si
c'est la bce qui fait la perte ya aucun
citoyen qui perd le moindre centime
c'est ça la grande différence à
l'échelle internationale est-ce que la
signature de la baie se perd pas un
pouls de sa passant ça c'est une
objection qui a été qui m'a été opposé
effectivement ce à quoi je réponds ceci
vous dis
non non non un surcroît de réponse aussi
est ce que vous croyez vraiment que la
fiabilité de l'euro aux dépens des fonds
propres de la bce aujourd'hui ses 10
milliards mais la réponse est non et
donc c'est pas de ça dont dépend la
fiabilité l'euro en revanche si
aujourd'hui les pays de la zone euro se
mettaient d'accord pour un grand plan de
reconstruction écologique de la zone
euro avec les marges de manoeuvre
budgétaires qui ont été dégagés grâce à
l'annulation de la dette publique les
2200 milliards et avec ça on finance un
grand plan de reconstruction écologique
de la totalité la zone euro je peux vous
dire que les gens vont se bousculer pour
avoir de l'euro parce qu'ils vont
comprendre que l'euro ça vaut quelque
chose si au contraire parce que on est
complètement obsédé par l'austérité
budgétaire et l'orthodoxie monétaire on
s'enfonce dans la déflation et que
l'europe devient un second japon mais
l'euro vaudra de moins en moins ça c'est
clair et donc la véritable véritables
responsables de la dévalorisation de
l'euro sur les marchés des changes se
serait pas une annulation coordonnée et
concertée de la dette publique au bilan
la baiss e céline actions liées à
l'orthodoxie budgétaire
l'idéologie politique et l'idéologie
économique c'est un refrain à tout un
tas de choses est ce qu'on peut avoir
votre point de vue sur l'idéologie
économique de ski ski il sort dans les
médias de l'idéologie de l'économie qui
nous est servie
souvent en fait il ya énormément de
l'espèce de lieux communs qui sont
répétés à droite et la gauche sans
beaucoup d'esprit critique c'est là que
mon avis un certain mode journaliste
pourrait faire davantage dans leur
travail je donne quelques exemples au
premier c'est ce fameux chiffres qui
circulent un peu partout selon lequel
la part des dépenses publiques dans le
pipe en france ce serait supérieur à 50
2% chiffres qui répétait en boucle par
le gouvernement le goleador la banque de
france par le président de la république
et par un certain nombre de médias
ce chiffre est faux alors ce chiffre est
correct mais ne dit pas ce qu'il prétend
dire c'est à dire si je vous dis les
dépenses publiques ses 52 % du pib vous
croyez vous dites ah bon alors donc les
dépenses privées c'est 48%
complémentaires et donc la france c'est
pas très loin de pyongyang c'est la
corée du nord on est étouffée par la
dépense publique et ses millions de
fonctionnaires qui travaillent pas
c'était et c'est dans ces salles
imaginaire qui est véhiculée par ce
chiffre or la vérité c'est que les
dépenses privées rapporté au pipe c'est
plus de 200% du pib et donc si je fais
la somme j'obtiens plus de 250 % du pib
là vous vous dites il ya un problème
parce que la somme fait plus de 100 %
donc ça veut bien dire que les 52 %
correspond pas à ce que je m'imagine
devoir être dans le pib l'astuce
provient du fait que le pib n'est pas la
somme des dépenses d'une économie qui
fait plus de 250 % du pib mais c'est la
somme de ce qu'on appelle les valeurs
ajoutées lorsque vous faites une dépense
que vous soyez une entreprise ou un
ménage et une partie de ses dépenses qui
n'est pas de la valeur ajoutée vous avez
pas créer de la valeur vous remboursez
juste par exemple la consommation
intermédiaire qui nous a permis de
produire un produit lorsqu'une
entreprise vend un produit effet un
chiffre d'affaires sur ce produit une
partie de ce chiffre d'affaires sert à
rembourser la consommation intermédiaire
ça fait pas la valeur ajoutée il faut
déduire sa du profit pour calculer la
valeur ajoutée de l'entreprise
donc si vous regardez la contribution de
la dépense publique à la valeur ajoutée
dans l'économie française retrouve et 22
pour ça non pas 52 et c'est très normal
il vous reste 78% de contribution du
secteur privé est la valeur ajoutée
française ces 22 % si vous retirez même
la dépenses liées à la défense à l'armée
française vont trouver 19 pour sa 18 19
ans et ce chiffre est stable depuis les
années 80 donc premièrement c'est pas
vrai qu'il ya une explosion de la
dépense publique deuxièmement c'est pas
vrai qu'on se rapproche de pyongyang en
fait en vérité la dépense publique est
insuffisante en france
troisièmement parce que nous les
français on adore se faire mal et se
comparer avec les allemands alors
évidemment à chaque fois j'entends et
regarder la dépense publique allemande
c'est beaucoup moins que la dépense
publique française en fait la dépense la
contribution des dépenses publiques en
allemagne au pib allemand ces 19 18 19 %
la différence avec nous c'est que nous
on a une armée
bombe et on a une bombe etc voilà est
donc en réalité si on compare ce qui est
comparable on est exactement au même
niveau que nos amis allemands donc il
n'ya pas c'est pas vrai qu'il ya une
dépense publique pléthorique en france
avec des fonctionnaires qui ne fichent
rien et de l'autre de l'autre côté
l'autre côté du rhin une espèce de sueur
efficacité la fonction publique même si
par ailleurs c'est vrai que par exemple
dans le traitement de la pandémie nos
amis allemands ont été beaucoup plus
efficace connu je vous fait rebondir sur
un papier qui est sorti dans le monde
aujourd'hui sur le début de la pandémie
on sait on s'est rendu compte que au
début de la pandémie on était déjà en
short pas d'anti viraux les stocks comme
un traître est papa de masques et ils
parlent pas d'antibiotiques comment ça
se fait mais ça c'est lié d'euros près
de vue à cette énergie non vous parliez
tout à l'heure village est plus libérale
qui est
qui et que en 2007 il ya eu un sénateur
qui s'appelait giro dans lesquelles j'ai
pas de relations familiales qui a
provoqué la création de ce qu'on appelle
l'eprus l'établissement de prévention et
de réponse aux urgences sanitaires eprus
très intelligemment avait dit à la suite
de la première vague coronavirus il faut
qu'on ait des stocks de masques il faut
qu'on ait des stocks d'enzymes pour
pouvoir faire du dépistage de manière
systématique et l'eprus à l'époque avec
budget pour le faire et si on avait eu
le coc vite de cette année en 2008 on
était tout aussi efficace que
ça cas pour la taiwan taiwan la corée du
sud qui n'ont pas eu besoin de se
confiner parce qu'ils ont mis en place
des tests une pratique de dépistage
extrêmement systématique le port du
masque généralisée pour tout le monde le
confinement pour ce qui était positif au
test etc etc
simplement depuis 2007 cette idéologie
post libéral qui habite une partie de
nos esprits fait qu'un certain nombre de
gens très peu éclairés se sont dit ah
oui mais en fait des stocks de masques
c'est nul c'est de l'argent perdu c'est
l'argent qui dort c'est de l'argent
public ne sert à rien éliminons ses
stocks de masques
et mignon cette assurance exactement
donc on a on a éliminé nos assurances au
motif qu'il faut faire du profit à court
terme le plus vite possible et le plus
possible dans des chaînes de valeur
international à flux tendu c'est ça le
l'idéologie qui nous tue aujourd'hui
donc face à la question de la pandémie
en fait en france nourrit fictivement en
est en short dès le mois de février
alors qu en fait le virus circule
probablement depuis le mois de décembre
peut-être même avant
l'islande a fait des tests de dépistage
un mois avant qu'ils le premier cas
positif qui apparaissent en islande nous
on a commencé à faire des dépistages
plusieurs jours voire plusieurs semaines
après que des premiers cas en fait
positif fuite apparue en france si on
avait fait les tests de dépistage donc
aujourd'hui c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles c'est pas impossible qu'on se
paye deuxième phase du confinement à
cause de la deuxième vague est en train
de gonfler petit à petit donc j'entends
que gouvernement serait en train de
réfléchir à un gros film en parisien
entre le 15 octobre et le 15 novembre à
peu près si on n'arrive pas à juguler
cette deuxième vague et si de nouveaux
nos services de réanimation sont
dépassés comme ça risque d'être le cas
puisqu'on n'est toujours pas en train de
mettre en oeuvre des stratégies de
dépistage efficace et systématiques en
france du retard sur le traitement
d'autres patients koala et xavier tard
qu on va peut-être se taper une épidémie
de grippe en plus une épine white david
à ce sujet c'est pas c'est pas
indifférent de dire d'ailleurs que le
confinement probablement va tuer
davantage que le virus lui-même à cause
de tous les patients qui souffraient de
tout à fait autre chose qu'on n'a pas pu
soigner dans des hôpitaux parce qu'on
est les hôpitaux étaient débordés
complètement accaparé par la question du
corps et d'un virus à cause par exemple
de toutes les maladies mentales qu'on
n'a pas pu traiter et qui se sont
aggravées pendant le confinement je
discutais pas plus tard qu'hier avec une
psychanalyste qui disait les choses très
intéressantes et bien qu'elle avait vu
qu'elle était très inquiète à l'idée
d'un deuxième confinement est que l ce
qu'elle avait observée pendant le
premier confinement c'était la tentation
très très forte chez une partie des
français les françaises d'une espèce de
régression intra-utérine c'est des mots
qu'elle a utilisé le carbone le sermon
de la cabane voilà vous êtes bien dans
votre petite cabane est finalement
l'altérité comme tel finit par vous
faire peur et ça c'est la mort de
l'humanité il faut comprendre ça c'est
extrêmement grave comme comme situation
donc moi je pense qu'il faut tout faire
pour éviter de confinement non pas en
sacrifiant les personnes qui vont mourir
mais en mettant en place une stratégie
de dépistage est évidemment de port du
masque extrêmement systématique ce que
le gouvernement français ne fait
toujours pas aujourd'hui
parler non pas de maladie mentale
mettent des pressions
il ya une gamine qui a fait un passage à
l'acte qui a fait une tentative de
suicide a réussi parce qu elle était
menacée par son coût ce d'être expulsé
parce qu'elle avait déjà des tendances
suicidaires
c'est scandaleux l'eau oui tout à fait
comment on arrive à avoir des gamins des
étudiants au pardon
qui se retrouvent confinés dans des
cages à lapins immonde avec des cafards
partout
et on leur met la pression derrière
c'est quoi ça manque d'humanité c'est la
course aux chiffres c'est je pense qu'il
faut se mettre dans la peau d'un jeune
des étudiants aujourd'hui qui n'a pas de
blé qui a peut-être une famille d qui
est déjà précaire voilà qui sait que ça
va être extrêmement difficile pour lui
ou pour elle de trouver un boulot et qui
en plus se voir enseigner des cours à
l'université dont il est intimement
convaincu qu'il ne sert pas à grand
chose pourquoi donc j'ai fait cette
expérience j'ai été invité il ya
quelques années il ya deux trois ans à
strasbourg par les étudiants du master 2
de strasbourg en économie comme
strasbourg toutes les universités
strasbourgeoises ont fusionné ça fait
beaucoup d'effectifs donc il y avait
quelque chose comme 400 étudiants ils
m'ont fait faire une conférence est à
l'issue de la conférence ils m'ont
demandé on dit voilà merci beaucoup pour
les conférences bon mais nous ça nous
fait quatre ans ou cinq ans qu'on nous
parle d'économie on nous a jamais parlé
d'écologie donc on a compris que ce
qu'on nous apprend ne sert à rien qu'est
ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui est en fait il
disait ça en face de leur prof
d'économie qui était à côté de moi qui
étais là donc c'était une espèce de
procès en fait qu'ils étaient en train
de mettre en scène en m'utilisant mois
comme tiers dans le conflit assez
violent au moins un titre un titre
symbolique qu'ils avaient alors avec
leur propre profit donc moi l'expérience
que je fais c'est qu'à une partie de la
jeune génération aujourd'hui qui nous
fait un procès à ma génération et la
génération du dessus sur le thème vous
les ok boomer tout ça vous êtes vous
êtes vous avez eu la belle vie pendant
des décennies vous nous livrez une terre
qui est relativement inhabitable en tout
cas qui risquent de lentilles on
continue dans une société qui va être
criblé de dettes et pas d'aidé publique
c'est pas le problème fondamental d'être
privés dans une société dans lequel le
marché du travail est tellement dégradée
qu'on aura pas de boulot et dans
laquelle on n'a pas d'actifs donc on est
la génération ninja dont income no job
non à 7 et c'est pour ça que vous avez
ça n'a pas de nom en com pas de revenus
nos jobs pas de travail et non à cette
pas d'actifs donc c'est pour ça vous
voyez des
des comportements du type suicidaire
chez un certain nombre de jeunes des
comportements dépressifs actifs addictif
des jeunes femmes des jeunes femmes qui
se prostituent dont vous avez une
explosion aujourd'hui de la prostitution
estudiantine et la prostitution
infantile de mineurs qui se prostituent
qui explose en ce moment qui fait les
délices d'une génération complètement
dévoyée pour qui c'est une bonne affaire
mais qui est en train de détruire une
génération donc je pense que est alors
en plus la question du confinement a été
vécue par une partie de ces jeunes comme
on nous sacrifie pour protéger la
génération du dessus donc je crois qu'il
faut entendre tout ça il faut absolument
que collectivement on décide de donner
sa chance effectivement à la jeune
génération le seul moyen de faire à mon
avis c'est de mettre en oeuvre ce grand
plan de reconstruction écologique dont
je parlais tout à l'heure qui est un
vrai projet de société qui peut créer
des emplois pour les jeunes rassurez
radio jobs donner du sens un horizon et
nous sortir de la panne de sens dans
laquelle on est enfermé aujourd'hui j'ai
une question provoque d'internet que
pense-t-il des catholiques anti écolo
qui lie l'encyclique lahoud à dos
l'homme note haussière il exactement ne
faudrait il ne faudrait il pas envisager
une excommunication pour les écocide
histoire de remettre les croyants face
aux réalités
cette question intéressante il y à il ya
une petite frange effectivement de
l'église catholique des catholiques qui
sont encore dans la délégation vis à vis
de leurs dates haussier
c'est une des raisons d'ailleurs pour
lesquelles on a fait cette délégation
française qui est allé voir le pape le 3
septembre qui a été emmenée par
monseigneur eric de moulins beaufort qui
est le président de la conférence
épiscopale de france
l'un des objectifs c'était aussi qu'une
partie des catholiques français voit que
la conférence épiscopale de france
s'engage du côté de l'écologie au même
titre que des personnalités publiques
comme juliette binoche audrey pulvar
valérie cabanne est bon premièrement
deuxièmement va y aller cabanès c'est
l'une des
des avocates qui milite en faveur des
reconnaissances de l'éco s'il est pour
en avoir discuté avec elle et avec le
père françois je rappelle à tout le
monde que le par françois a pris
position publiquement en faveur de la
reconnaissance de négocier donc c'est
pas une position magistérielle qui
engagerait par exemple l'infaillibilité
pontificale mais c'est une position
publique très ferme de la part du pape
sur laquelle je n'imagine pas une
seconde qu'il puisse revenir donc ça
veut dire deux mots point de vue que
dans les rangs catholiques la question
déco s'est déréglé c'est ce doit être un
crime qui doit être reconnu par la
communauté internationale
notre église catholique a pris position
très clairement en faveur de la
reconnaissance de l'écocide
d'autres questions internet qui nous
rebond qui ne va nous faire rebondir
encore sur le japon pourquoi avoir une
bûche est investi au japon ne serait-ce
un car le japon est endetté
principalement auprès de ses habitants
net une fois une fois ses dettes
annulées non ça c'est mal mais a formulé
le japon est il vraiment dans le rouge
finalement au point d'interrogation le
parallèle avec la france vous dit il
malgré tout c'est une bonne question a
donc à ce que l'internaute qui dit ça
cesse et que la dette publique japonaise
qui est approximativement de 250 % du
pib japonais donc c'est énorme nous nous
approchons de 120 125 donc on est des
petits joueurs à côté du japon mais la
grande différence est que la dette
publique japonaise est détenue à 95% par
les japonais donc c'est vrai que le
trésor japonais a remis en place en fait
un circuit avec la banque centrale du
japon qui ressemble beaucoup au circuit
de bloch lainé qu'on avait mis en place
nous en france après la seconde guerre
mondiale et qui a permis de financer la
reconstruction de l'économie française
autrement dit le japon est en train de
rouler sa dette avec sa propre banque
centrale et ceci est acceptée par les
japonais parce que les japonais savent
bien que c'est eux qui les tiennent leur
propre dette publique donc au fond ça
devient un problème interne au japon et
un transfert du remboursement de la
dette publique d'une génération à
l'autre ça veut pas dire que c'est
simple mais ça veut dire que c'est
beaucoup plus facile que ce que nous
avons à faire nous les français parce
que malheureusement le trésor français a
eu la très mauvaise idée de confier la
gestion de la dette publique française à
des banques privées qui n'ont rien
trouvé de plus intelligent à faire que
de la vendre à des non résidents
français
donc la dette publique française est
détenu au deux tiers aujourd'hui par des
non résidents et un tiers seulement par
des résidents français par comparaison
par exemple l'italie dont la dette
publique est bien supérieure à la nôtre
elle est à 160 165 % du pib aujourd'hui
donc l'italie est en train de se
rapprocher d'une situation grecque
raison pour laquelle par exemple la
survie de la zone euro va se poser la
question de la survie va se poser dans
les mois ou les années qui viennent mais
la grande différence c'est que la dette
publique italienne est détenue aux deux
tiers par des italiens donc l'italie en
fait et beaucoup moins vulnérables à une
réaction aux marchés financiers que la
france donc c'est l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles d'ailleurs à mon avis il faut
se dépêcher de faire cette annulation de
la dette publique française au bilan de
la bce parce que ça va nous redonner une
bouffée d'oxygène budgétaire que nous
n'aurons pas le jour où les
investisseurs internationaux vont
resserrer la vis de la dette publique
française
questions très simples mais lourd de
conséquences lourdes de conséquences
quelles sont vos perspectives pour les 5
années à suivre
est-ce qu'on va est ce qu'on va
est ce qu'on vend vraiment en prendre
plein la tête en tant que française
qu'on va se transformer au portugal de
1960 en grèce de 2012 en 2011 par vous
est ce que est ce que parce que le nôtre
chef de l'état kim jong macro nous nulle
part elle avec l'accord et désolé nous
annonce 2 millions de chômeurs à deux
ans un million chaque année oui
s'arrêter aux deux premières années
on a quand même notre tempérament de
français ça risque de chauffer quand
même un peu parce que
quand on va se retrouver avec un pouvoir
d'achat qui va être encore amputée ça va
amener tout gilet jaune voire une autre
couleur un peu plus énervé dans les rues
certes on a une capacité de maintien de
la population avec une technologie du
maintien de l'ordre extraordinaire qu'on
exporte
dans les pays insurrectionnelle
c'est magnifique et
c'est trivial non ça va chauffer ou ça
va chauffer entre les sages eux savent
accueillir l'elysée a très peur que ça
chauffe cet automne
c'est pas la première personne qui nous
dit automne ça va chauffer ça va
chauffer j'ai pas dit que ça allait
chauffer j'évite l'elysée a très peur
que ça chauffe
conte et la perspective d'avoir de
nouveau des gilets jaunes voir défiler
rouge comme il ya eu en tunisie où des
gilets violets ça me semble assez clair
au sens où disons la situation
économique va certainement être très
très dégradée dans les mois qui viennent
donc vous connaissez les chiffres on va
se prendre au moins un million de
chômeurs en plus on va se prendre au
moins 10 % du pib en moins et des
publics qui va qu'il va problème très
très certainement est supérieur à 120%
du pib donc c'est à dire qu'il ya toute
une série d'indicateurs macroéconomiques
ils vont être très très dégradé là
dessus il faut ajouter effectivement
disons le dérèglement climatique et
écologique qui continuent de saper
progressivement les écosystèmes naturels
qui nous font vivre
à commencer par littoral français le
manque d'eau en milieu rural français
savait que il ya des projections qui ont
été faites par wri2 new york et le qui
est le grand think tank à washington de
broadway social chez tube qui montre que
on pourrait manquer jusqu'au moins de
40% en accès à l'eau potable en france
en 2040 2040 c'est quand même juste
après demain et ça c'est la fourchette
basse il se pourrait que ce soit
davantage ce qui veut dire que la
plainte chronique on entend aujourd'hui
de la part d'un certain nombre
d'agriculteurs français en milieu rural
qui disent ya plus d'eau ça ne plante on
va l'entendre tous les ans maintenant
très probablement est par ailleurs
beaucoup plus violente et la façon plus
violente parce que vous et moi on peut
vivre quelques jours sans électricité
mais personne ne peut vivre sans eau
donc donc ces questions là vont en plus
continuer de saper les écosystèmes
naturels qui nous font vivre là dessus
pour continuer de se faire peur il faut
ajouter la perspective possible d'un
krach financier palito exclut donc on
est aujourd'hui au sommet d'une bulle
financière absolument gigantesque
beaucoup plus grande que celle de 2008
qui a été essentiellement alimentée ces
dernières années par les politiques
monétaires non conventionnelles les
banques centrales qui ne savent pas quoi
faire parce qu'elle se dise si j'arrête
le robinet la bulle explose pourquoi
parce qu'il a un certain nombre
d'investisseurs privés qui sont
surendettés qui se sont endettés pour
profiter de la hausse du prix des actifs
financiers et qui si on arrête la manne
monétaire qui inondent aujourd'hui les
marchés interbancaires donc pas nos
comptes en banque a nommé les marchés
interbancaires donc la partie supérieure
de l'olympe dont je parlais tout à
l'heure si on arrête cette manne
militaire là ces investisseurs là ne
peuvent plus rembourser leurs dettes et
donc sont obligés de vendre leurs actifs
financiers pour rembourser leurs dettes
s'il vend des actifs financiers le cours
des actifs s'effondre et on a un krach
financier il ya déjà eu des frais mais
des frémissements assez inquiétant la
semaine dernière à wall street et donc
ça traduit une très grande nervosité des
marchés financiers on peut pas exclure
qu'ils aient un krach financier dans
l'est dans les semaines qui viennent je
suis pas en train de vous prédire qu'il
va y avoir un krach financier je suis
juste en train de dire que ça peut pas
être exclue donc certaine manière on
peut avoir
la tempête parfaite c'est à dire
l'accumulation de toutes ces de tous ses
shopi dit j oui voilà
je suis pas je vois pas de préparation
n'a pas du gouvernement français face à
ce type de scénario alors que le
principe de prudence la plus élémentaire
et le souci de maintenir la souveraineté
de la france devraient nous inciter
aujourd'hui à prendre ce type de
scénario au sérieux et à nous préparer à
ça je ne suis pas sûr du tout que le
gouvernement actuel si près pas vous a
vu l'état de préparation etc locaux
vides bon alors
c'est clair je veux j'adore après la
question qui était posée c'était à 5 ans
qu'elle est à perspective si on se
ressaisit pas ce que je voudrais arrêter
un petit peu aussi de simplement brossé
un tableau apocalyptique de la situation
on est capable de se ressaisir
la convention citoyenne à mon avis la de
vous démontrer c'est à dire que il y a
une conscience très très vive à mon avis
au sein de la population française de de
la gravité la situation y compris la
gravité de la situation écologique les
derniers à comprendre c'est la petite
élite le 1% dans le tiers éduquer
supérieur qui vit ensemble en centre
ville qui n'a aucune idée de ce que
vivent les autres français et qui
comprend pas qu'on manque d'eau par
exemple en milieu rural français par
exemple aux mines et de la creuse dans
de paris oui oui même à une heure de
paris tout à fait absolument donc si on
serait saisie si on met par exemple en
annuler la dette publique détenue par la
bce au bilan de la bce on met en place
aussi par exemple c'est un autre procédé
non j'ai pas parlé mais qui qui est
défendue à mon avis à juste titre par
alain grandjean et nicolas dufresne dans
leurs bouquins sur la monnaie et
écologique on met en place de la monnaie
hélicoptère c'est à dire qu'on utilise
le pouvoir de création monétaire de la
bce pour financer non pas par de la
dette mais de la monnaie libre de la
monnaie que personne ne remboursera de
la monnaie actifs n'ont pas demandé
d'être un grand plan d'investissements
verts en france
rénovation thermique des bâtiments
mobilité verte réaménagement du
territoire le train l'industrie verte
donc une industrie low tech donc je peux
détailler tout ça mais tout ça ce sont
des chantiers qui vont nous occuper
pendant des décennies qui sont
extraordinairement créateur d'emploi qui
diminue notre dépendance au pétrole et
donc et puis également au gaz et donc à
vladimir poutine ce qui boucle avec ce
qu'on se disait
nos amis qui coûte des journalistes dans
les ambassades là comment il s'appelle
déjà
voilà voilà les l'arabie saoudite 16
heures voilà par exemple et qui
améliorent la balance commerciale
française donc si on met ça en place on
est capable de se ressaisir et on est
capable également d'avoir une vertu
d'exemplarité vis à vis du reste de la
planète parce que je peux vous dire
c'est laisser mon expérience en agence
française de développement qui a
beaucoup de gens qui regardent ce que
fait la france en particulier l'amérique
latine mais pas uniquement en amérique
latine en afrique évidemment l'afrique
francophone mais pas uniquement pourquoi
parce qu'ils savent qu'on est un pays
très éduqués on appelait irish et on a
un pays qui est capable de prendre des
décisions fortes quand il le faut la
nuit du 4 août 1789
les gens savent ce que ça veut dire et
donc on est capable de se ressaisir moi
j'en suis certain on est capable en
france de mettre en place un vrai
nouveau projet de société de
décarbonation notre économie de
transition pas sûr que la boli
l'abolition des privilèges de la nuit du
4 août ça résonne de chez beaucoup de
personnes quand même encore si si si si
et non non c'est pas vrai du tout en
amérique latine vous savez que les
intellos katyn mais pas en france en
france aussi john ince atomisant les
gilet jaune peut-être que telle ou telle
ne sais pas ce que c'est qu'un du 4 août
mais il a très bien compris que
l'abolition des privilèges c'est un
geste constitutive de l'identité
française ils avaient percé dans l'au
delà des lieux régicide et ils résistent
ils ont coupé la tête au roi tout à fait
tellement elle avait passé en angleterre
c'est aller à londres comment c'était la
belle époque quoi donc l'orgie 6 2 non
j'ai pas dit ça simplement au moment où
on a coupé la tête du roi et ça c'est un
élément par exemple que j'ai défendue
dans ma thèse de théologie au moment où
on coupe la tête du roi
en france en dix sept en plein xviiie
siècle fin xviiie siècle qu'est ce qu'on
est en train de faire on est en train de
dire il n'est pas légitime qu'un
individu parmi d'autres s'arroge le
droit ou la prétention de représenter la
source du pouvoir absolu sur le trône
monarchique le godet ou par exemple de
la monnaie ça c'est un autre sujet je
peux à l'instant mais quand on coupe la
tête du roi la question des
révolutionnaires c'est c'est vrai que
c'est aussi de se redonner le pouvoir de
création monétaire mais surtout de le
remettre entre les mains des citoyens
oui en ce sens là je suis d'accord avec
vous mais donc ça c'est très important
ce que ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que la laïcité donc le reflux de la
fusion entre le disons l'autorité
spirituelle de l'église d'un côté et le
pouvoir politique de l'autre c'est aussi
un geste constitutive de l'identité
française de ce point de vue là la loi
1905 en france est fondamental la
laïcité le refus l'idolâtrie d'un
pouvoir monarchique qui est ce qu'on est
en train de réinstaller en france
aujourd'hui donc symboliquement ils ont
l'elysée aujourd'hui rejoue la scène de
la monarchie
le refus donc de l'idolâtrie monarchique
et la nécessité d'un d'une vraie
délibération démocratique avec
l'abolition des privilèges sassi
constitutive de la modernité et de la
france à mon avis donc c'est ça qu'il
faut qu'il faut restaurer aujourd'hui en
france puisque c'est ça qu'on est en
train de perdre c'est quoi votre sujet
de tests déjà composer un monde en
commun c'est-à-dire redonner le pouvoir
à tous de contribuer à la construction
du monde et d'un monde commun partage et
avec tous et le titre c'était composer
un monde en commun une théologie
politique de l'anthropocène une
théologie politique c'est quoi ce une
forme de propagande ne rompaient du tour
une théologie politique c'est une
réflexion sur la conséquence politique
de ce que l'expérience chrétienne peut
apporter en termes spirituel autrement
dit je peux expliquer un tout petit peu
cette affaire-là
au xixème siècle on a eu surtout du côté
protestant l'idée que
l'expérience de foi l'expérience
spirituelle c'était une expérience
privée qui nous regardent chaque
individu que le dimanche matin quand il
va à la messe est chez soi quand il fait
sa prière
moi je crois pas du tout à ça et c'est
pas ça la grande tradition chrétienne la
grande tradition chrétienne c'est que
l'expérience chrétienne est une
expérience spirituelle de libération à
l'égard de toutes les hydrolats
d'idolâtrie politique qui nous maintient
dans la servitude la dernière grande
expression de ça ça a été la théologie
de la libération en amérique latine qui
a beaucoup oeuvré pour lutter contre les
juntes militaires qui avaient pris le
pouvoir dans un certain nombre de pays
d'amérique latine je donne un exemple
c'est pas un jésuite mais le dominicain
henry burin des roziers sur ce départ
fait un nom mais c'est un grand monsieur
le dominicain henry burin des roziers a
été un avocat au brésil qui pendant
toute sa vie à lutter pour la cause des
paysans sans terre dépossédé par la
junte militaire brésilienne bon ça c'est
la grande idée de la théologie de la
libération mais fondamentalement c'est
la grande idée du christianisme qui est
que l'expérience spirituelle c'est pas
un petit truc dans ma bulle dans ma
régression intra-utérine favorisée par
le confinement c'est une expérience de
libération qui a des conséquences
politiques
donc la pointe de ma thèse c'est de dire
la modernité que les français invente
avec d'autres mais à auquel ils
contribuent de manière massive au xviiie
siècle c'est une expérience chrétienne
fondamentalement l'évangile a quelque
chose à voir avec la démocratie parce
que l'évangile n'est pas compatible avec
les dolly et l'idolâtrie de la monarchie
du corps du roi siégeant sur le trône
est la meilleure preuve de ceci c'est ce
qu'on lit dans les évangiles est ce que
j'expliquais dans ma thèse notamment
dans l'évangile de luc au moment d'un
récit qui est pas très connu qui
s'appelle récit de l'ascension
le christ le messie ressuscite
rencontre ses apôtres et ses apôtres lui
dise bon est ce que c est maintenant qu
enfin tu va rétablir la monarchie
davidique la royauté et bouter hors de
palestine ou hors disons delà de la
judée romaine le pouvoir aux mains parce
que c'était ça la grande attente
messianique de du judaïsme du 1er siècle
c'est-à-dire le messie devait libérer
israël de l'oppression romaine et le
christ on refuse de faire ça il refuse
de s'asseoir sur le trône de david et
disparaît dans le ciel est donc
l'interprétation j'en propose c'est de
dire le christ le messie pour les
chrétiens a refusé de s'asseoir sur le
trône donc il a laissé le lieu du
pouvoir vide de manière que nous
puissions apprendre à construire
démocratiquement les figures du lien
social qui vont occuper le lieu du
pouvoir
et une certaine manière ça veut dire que
pour les chrétiens idolâtré le roi s'est
pas être fidèle à l'évangile c'est
incompatible en fondamentalement avec
l'évangile même s'il se trouve que c'est
ce que notre église soutenu pendant des
siècles mais c'était une erreur et donc
ceci pour dire que être chrétien
aujourd'hui ça veut dire faut
fondamentalement être démocrate être
favorable à la de modernité très
favorable de la séparation des pouvoirs
notamment la séparation des églises et
de l'état et évidemment et c'est un
autre aspect que je développe dans ma
thèse c'est être écologiste aujourd'hui
fondamentalement pour les noms des
listes quand j'entends ressuscité
s'envoler dans le ciel
ça fait un peu les gens de pour enfants
quand même normal ça fait un petit peu
une histoire qu'on raconte dans le
village pour faire croire aux gens qu'on
est en ligne directe avec
là haut
c'est pas un peu
archaïque c'est pas un peu ssq et je
vais j'ai peut-être choquer ta foi
est-ce que croire dans un ami imaginaire
c'est pas un petit peu ce le plus
approprié sa capacité à agir
la question c'est quel est le sens que
je donne au récit de l'ascension et aux
récits évangéliques fille je m'imagine
que c'est un dessin animé du t-bond à 10
n'est effectivement c'est une régression
infantile et on n'est pas très loin du
compte du père noël je suis d'accord
mais là le mélange de la question c'est
est ce que c'est vraiment ça le sens des
évangiles
donc la seule réponse qu'on puisse
apporter à ceux ci c'est lorsque je fais
moi-même par exemple et certains d'entre
nous l'ont fait pendant confinement
l'expérience de la mort la mort d'un
proche de quelqu'un que j'aime au la
mienne possible on m'annonce que j'ai un
cancer et qui me reste trois mois à
vivre quel sens que je donne à mon
existence dans cette épreuve là et
qu'elles sentent je donne notamment aux
expériences de joie et d'amour que j'ai
traversés dans ma vie
est-ce que je crois que tout ceci ne
valait rien puisque la personne que
j'aimais mortes ou puisque je vais
mourir notre moi où est ce que je crois
que ça valait quelque chose et que ce
que ça valait traverse l'épreuve de la
mort
d'une manière mystérieuse que je ne
comprends pas pour laquelle j'ai aucune
démonstration mathématique est à portée
mais qui fait que j'ai la conviction que
l'amour que j'ai partagée avec la
personne qui m'était cher et qui
aujourd'hui disparu
cet amour là à pois d'éternité si je
crois que c'est un poil éternité
adore ça le récit de la résurrection dit
quelque chose de sa s'agit pas de
s'imaginer un film hollywoodien avec un
coq était in her kibo où j'étais il ya
eu des films atroce qui ont essayé de
montrer ça ça n'a rien à voir avec
l'évangile parce que c'est entre ouvrir
les eaux oui voilà
la question c'est de faire une
expérience spirituelle et de se dire
quel est le sens que j'attribue à mon
existence de manière très très concrètes
quand je suis confronté à des
expériences radical qui sont des lieux
un peu extrême la mort d'un proche
damienne et c'est
l'expérience religieuse elle nous
rejoint à cet endroit là et elle dit est
ce que tu crois que tu peux malgré tout
trouver un sens global à ton existence
ou non alors je peux
m'enfermer dans le désespoir et dit
ouais tout ça est absurde en fait j'ai
aimé on a aimé mais tout ça ça valait
rien c'était du vent c'est possible j'ai
cette liberté là j'ai aussi la liberté
de dire je ne sais pas très bien ce que
ça signifiait mais je crois
fondamentalement que ça valait le coup
de le vivre que ça vaut le coup de
continuer de me lever le matin et que ça
a un sens qui traverse l'épreuve de la
mort c'est ça que dit le christianisme
jésus il était blond avec des cheveux
bouclés probablement pas puisque ils
étaient juifs palestiniens je dois dire
c'est ça comment que de dire
non pas cananéens nono parce que les
canadiens sont pas des juifs non il est
pas qu à menin il était judéens né à
nazareth et transféré en fin d'année
avec les aime pardon et vivant à
nazareth toute son enfance alors est ce
que
on se dirige vers un crack peut-être si
on se tape vers un crack est ce que le
blanchit mollet les opérations
frauduleuses ont pouvoir être un petit
peu plus nettoyer ou passer à la trappe
est ce que pendant les krachs boursiers
les banques en profite pour publier n'en
ont pas l'être ou alors les krachs
boursiers sont pas du tout une bonne une
bonne nouvelle de mon point de vue pour
ce qui est de la transparence financière
au contraire parce que la situation
devient tellement catastrophique que les
banques ont un pouvoir de chantage sur
les autorités publiques pour dire ne
nous cherchez pas des poux dans la tête
parce qu'on va très très mal qui devient
colossal je pense qu'il faut prendre
conscience du fight to fail to lie to me
too big to jail joe big to jail aussi
une banque comme bnp paribas a un bilan
dont la taille est du même ordre de
grandeur que le pib de la france
donc si demain matin bnp paribas faisait
faillite l'état français serait
incapable d'honorer la loi européenne
qui fait obligation à l'état de garantir
tous les cons de l'epo jusqu'à hauteur
de 100 millions je pense qu'il faut
prendre conscience du fait que déjà au
moment du naufrage du ce du secteur
bancaire chypriote
c'était pas clair que l'état chypriote
étaient capables de garantir tous les
comptes des polices priode jusqu'à
hauteur de 100 millions euros raison
pour laquelle un commissaire européen
assez mal inspiré a commencé à dire
publiquement bon écouter dans le catch
it on n'était pas obligé d'appliquer la
loi la garantie des cons des dépôts et
puis il a été rapidement rattrapé par
les bretelles par les banquiers qui
l'ont rappelé en disant mais écoutez là
vous dites n'importe quoi parce que si
vous commencez à laisser entendre
citoyens européens qu'on ne va pas
garantir leurs comptes de dépôt ils vont
retirer l'argent des banques il a toutes
nos banques seront en faillite donc le
lendemain le même commissaire européen
fait une contre conférence de presse par
exemple n'ont écouté je me suis trompé
ma langue a fourché évidemment on va
appliquer la loi et garantir les comptes
de dépôt des chypriotes mais donc ça
veut dire que dans le cas extrêmement
facile et est ridicule en termes de
taille du du secteur bancaire chypriote
déjà ça posait un problème bon je vous
laisse imaginer ce qu'il en est pour la
france donc en vérité je termine juste
là dessus nos banques ont un pouvoir de
chantage colossale sur les états à la
mesure de leur taille et leur gigantisme
comme c'est un cartel oui bien sûr que
c'est un cartel sien c'est un secteur le
secteur bancaire est un secteur qui
n'est absolument pas concurrentiels au
sens où si un oligopole dans lequel il
la concurrence est très imparfaite et où
les banques se font des cadeaux entre
elles et empêche d'ailleurs un certain
nombre d'autres banques devenir leur
faire concurrence je donne un exemple
mais triodos qui est une banque
néerlandaise qui est remarquable à tous
égards c'est une banque qui ne finance
que les projets écologiques dont les
fonds propres représentent 20% du bilan
de la banque contre 3% pour toutes les
entreprises banques françaises et dont
les écarts de salaire à l'intérieur de
la banque vont de 1 à 5 contre 1 à 1000
pour la société générale et bnp paribas
dit bonjour à frédéric on dit bonjour à
frédéric oudéa
triodos depuis des années demandent à
l'état français d'avoir le droit
d'ouvrir des comptes en banque pour les
citoyens français est un français comme
par exemple le lui refuse pourquoi parce
que ce serait une concurrence formidable
à l'égard de nos grandes banques
systémiques savent très bien que le jour
ou quel giraud continue de faire la
publicité pour trio noise comme il le
fait par tous le jour où les français
ont la possibilité d'ouvrir un compte en
banque c'est très facile vont tous vider
leur compte en banque chez bnp la
société générale pour n'ouvrir chetrit
de valois de faire sa fière d'appuyer
sur a de faire de la publicité je suis
pas payée par triodos j'ai pas droit de
dénigrer bnp paribas d'ailleurs j'ai pas
dit man bnp paribas revanche j'ai le
droit de dire que triolo c'est une mère
formidable mais voyez ceci pour dire que
est un français refusent d'octroyer à
triodos le droit d'accueillir des
comptes de dépôt pour éviter qu'elles
fassent concurrence à nos grandes
banques nationales ce qui est un des
symptômes j'ai fait le secteur bancaire
est tout sauf un secteur concurrentiel
en cas de krach comme ça quand ça tangue
quand il ya des grandes vagues les
investissements les plus sur les actifs
les plus sûrs les shoes ou a pas se
faire tondre
c'est quoi ça sans donner de conseils
d'investissement alors du côté des
traders je peux vous dire le réflexe
atavique des traders sur les marchés
financiers ces trois valeurs c'est l'or
le franc suisse et le pétrole au nom de
kuro de pays nordiques non non non
beaucoup moins le franc suisse pourquoi
parce qu'ils savent qu'une bonne partie
d'entre eux est des plus riches de la
planète ont un compte en banque en
suisse et que donc ce sera dernier pays
qu on lâchera pas qu'on a absolument
besoin de garder ses économies en suisse
autour du lac de genève dans le canton
de zug et
le pétrole parce qu'ils sont convaincus
que l'on aura toujours besoin de pétrole
et l'or parce que c'est une espèce de
vieux réflexes
voilà maintenant je suis pas en train de
conseiller à quiconque y en train de
suivre cette émission d'investir dans
l'or le pétrole nous francs suisses pour
sauver ces économies plus
lors leurs papiers leur physique ils
sont mission positionner comment ils se
font livrer l'horizon non bien sûr
personne se fait livrer leurs simplement
vous acheter des actifs dérivés sur l'or
qui ce qui vous minent le fait que vous
êtes propriétaire de l'or
christine lagarde nous parle d'un grand
reset ça veut dire quoi ça consiste en
cours c
c'est intéressant parce que christine
lagarde ne vient pas du monde de la
finance et
elle a pris la direction du fmi il ya
quelques années alors que christine
lagarde elle vient du monde delà du
droit
fondamentalement c'est pas une
financière et elle a l'art de prendre
des positions qui sont relativement
iconoclaste dans la sphère de la finance
mais qui très souvent me paraissent
assez justifiée donc moi j'ai une
certaine sympathie et une certaine
confiance dans le fait que cette femme
là est capable de prendre des positions
fortes que des financiers qui sont tenus
par leurs propres intérêts ne seront pas
capables de prendre s'ils sont un jour
dans la même position qu'elle a la tête
de la bce ça veut dire est que
aujourd'hui la bce est corseté par les
grandes banques et donc dans une
situation extrêmement compliquée ou à la
fois elle sait que c'est elle qui tient
le robinet monétaire qui permet de
maintenir un flot des banques et elle
n'a pas intérêt personne n'a intérêt à
ce que les grandes banques fassent
faillite pour les raisons que j'ai dit
les trois minutes en même temps à mon
avis le grand sujet et je pense que
christine lagarde est capable de faire
cette conversion intellectuelle c'est de
mettre en oeuvre une politique monétaire
écologique
il ya quelques années on disait
l'intersection entre le fmi et la
question écologique c'est christine
lagarde qui était la seule à y croire au
fmi c'est pas impossible aujourd'hui
l'intersection entre la bce et
l'écologie ce soit de nouveau christine
lagarde puisse allah seul à y croire moi
je pense qu'elle est capable dans les
mois et les années qui viennent de
prendre une position forte et de
comprendre que l'avenir de l'euro et
l'avenir de l'europe se joue dans la
faculté de la banque centrale européenne
à mettre en oeuvre une politique
monétaire verte pour financer les
investissements dans les infrastructures
vertes dont nous avons besoin vu adultes
in the room j'ai pas vu le j'ai pas vu
le film non pas du tout j'ai lu des
extraits du bouquin de varoufakis si
c'est ça le sujet mais j'ai pas vu le
film
question
internet la claque au vide c'est une
punition de dieu c'est le jugement
dernier c'est c'est quoi c'est pas du
tout ça tout ça n'a rien à voir avec le
christianisme au passage pas du tout la
co vide c'est le résultat de deux
facteurs alors on pourrait dire 3 mai de
essentiellement c'est le rapprochement
des humains avec des populations
animales que nous ne connaissons pas qui
est lié à la destruction de la
biodiversité donc l'exemple le plus
fameux c'est la déforestation à mesure
que nous mettons en oeuvre la
déforestation nous nous rapprochons
animaux qui vivent dans les forêts
profondes que nous ne connaissons pas et
face auxquels notre système immunitaire
n'a pas de défense et donc nous
récupérons les virus de ces animaux face
auquel ne sommes pas protégés donc le
lac au vide c'est un exemple de ceux ci
et puisque c'est un virus qui provient
de la chauve souris et qui a transité
jusqu'à l'homme via le pangolin à
travers le fait que ne probablement le
régime est pas sûr quand même voyez-vous
votre chose peu importe mais voyez le
point c'est que nous nous rapprochons
nous les humains de foyers viraux
associés à des animaux que nous ne
connaissons pas et que nous ne
fréquentons pas ça c'est là donc donc le
ca c'est le grand thème de la
destruction de la biodiversité le
deuxième sujet dans la dans la cabine
c'est la très grande facilité avec
laquelle ce virus s'est répandu sur la
totalité de la planète et ça c'est la
mondialisation la globalisation
marchande qui fait qu'on a une pandémie
en trois mois pandémie mondiale en trois
mois alors qu'on n'a jamais eu ça
précédemment on a déjà eu des pandémies
mondiales y compris au moyen âge on n'a
jamais une pandémie mondiale entre moi
et ça ça va se multiplier dans les
années qui viennent pourquoi parce que
le lobe l'être humain est le super
prédateur de la planète
donc si je suis un virus aujourd'hui et
ma tendance évolutive c'est de trouver
des supports qui me permettent de me
développe de me développer je vais me
développer beaucoup plus vite si
j'arrive sur un humain que s'il arrive
sur leur and alaska qui est en train de
disparaître et donc ça veut dire que
nous sommes la proie privilégiée pour
tous les virus qui vont avoir tendance à
se déplacer à se déployer sur la planète
dans les années qui viennent on n'a pas
parlé de la turquie
on n'a pas parlé de cette grande
puissance qui va être libéré bientôt de
certaines chaînes lui a imposée il ya
une centaine d'années
vous et de ce don ce dont je veux parler
dans et la turquie les migrants la
position religieuse de la turquie est ce
que c'est une position qui est
simplement clientéliste est ce que c'est
une position qui est
dans leur chaîne est ce que ces gars
dogan qui se met en grand chevalier de
l'islam ouais moi j'interprète je suis
pas un spécialiste de la turquie
j'interprète la position d'erdogan comme
étant du populisme qui instrumentalisent
la religion est l'islam en particulier à
des fins politiques donc si j'étais
musulman aujourd'hui je ne me résoudrai
pas de ce que faire de rennes avec avec
l'islam
maintenant en tant qu'européen ma
position c'est que nous devrions avoir
une position beaucoup plus ferme avec la
turquie dans la mesure où la turquie
aujourd'hui exerce un pouvoir de
chantage colossal avec les migrants
qu'elle contient dans son pays qu'elle
est prêt à lâcher entre guillemets sur
l'europe et donc d'une certaine manière
la turquie est en train de négocier ça
avec nous en nous disant ah mais si vous
ne faites pas si vous m'énervez si vous
ne faites pas ce que je vous demande moi
je lâche le million et demi de réfugiés
que je suis capable d'envoyer sur
l'europe continentale
face à ceux ci à mon avis l'europe
devrait parler d'une voix beaucoup plus
forte une voix unie pour avoir une
position politique ferme vis-à-vis
d'erdogan ce qui ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui
donc les turcs savent pas plus
économiquement parleront ils sont pas
exposés aussi bien sûr c'est une
économie qui est qui cour des très
grands risques aujourd'hui bien
évidemment tout à fait ça c'est clair
mais disons j'aurais tendance à dire
pour ce qui est vous voyez bien aussi
les manoeuvres militaro diplomatique de
la turquie vis-à-vis de la grèce
vis-à-vis de chypre qui finissent qui
sont aussi liées par exemple à volonté
la part des douanes de d'exploiter des
ressources gazières en méditerranée qui
sont absolument pas compatible avec les
conventions et les accords qui ont été
passés autour de temps voilà autour de
la méditerranée sont ces les accords de
le traiter de comment ça s'appelle vous
allez me dire dans un stade de genève
donc danse pas je ne sais pas si genève
tevez higuain ouais le point c'est à mon
avis à une position politique avoir
vis-à-vis des douanes c'est un
traitement politique vis-à-vis d'un chef
d'état populiste qui utilise tous les
instruments qui sont à sa disposition
militaire diplomatique religieux pour
parvenir à ses fins vous aviez parlé de
la deutsche bank ça fait dire ça fait
des années qu'on parle de la deutsche
bank d'ailleurs on va parler peut-être
cinq six ans avec hervé de quart monde
qui était anciennement à la midland et à
la chase manhattan bank ancien
vice-président de la commission
trilatérale europe il était déjà très
inquiet pour la deutsche bank est-ce
qu'on peut rentrer plus dans le détail
de la deutsche bank je n'ai pas
d'informations privilégiées sur l'état
du bilan de la deutsche bank aujourd'hui
ce que je sais c'est qu'il ya un an et
demi deux ans un à deux jours a commencé
la deutsche bank a commencé à vaciller
très fortement à telle enseigne que
qu'angela merkel a dû faire une
déclaration publique en disant nous ne
laisserons pas tomber la deutsche bank
bon ce qui était une manière de
reconnaître que la situation était très
grave voilà depuis lors apparemment la
deutsche bank s'est refait une santé
bilancielle mais j'ai pas d'informations
précises sur l'état du bilan d'ocha
manque aujourd'hui
va prendre quelques questions internet
que pense-t-il de l'effondrement est-ce
que la coulpe cela collapse l'ogive déjà
entendu parler moi j'ai une question
plus plus plus en détail tous ces plans
de relance le plan de relance français
le plan de relance européen
qu'on soit d'accord qu'on soit pas
d'accord le plan de relance selon la
galerie rousset pour faire une
transition écologique créé de l'emploi
grâce à sa sphère de la croissance ou de
la décroissance est-ce que c'est de la
croissance négative comme notre ami
christine lagarde elle
à jouer avec la langue et c'est quoi
est-ce que gaël giraud il veut de la
croissance ou de la décroissance est-ce
que son plan de relance écologique de
d'isolation le tout ça à la fin des fins
c'est quoi c'est de la croissance en
termes numéraire ouais premièrement sur
l'accolade solo jpy qui amène première
question là dessus après j'y arriverai
sur les seins énormes question d'un
croissance verte sur la cnaps l'asie
donc vous connaissez cette disons il ya
un certain imaginaire qui entoure le
concept d'effondrement dont aujourd'hui
un ami comme pablo serving se défend
mais qui malheureusement est quand même
véhicule et par toute une nébuleuse de
collapse dogues qui croient que il ya un
événement unique du lundi soir ou mardi
matin il va y avoir je ne sais pas un
grand black out et plus rien ne sera
pareil après par rapport à ce qu'on
avait avant cet imaginaire la de la
grande bifurcation je n'y crois pas une
seconde c'est à dire que ce que nous
faisons aujourd'hui c'est toute une
série d'effondrements partiel qui ont
déjà eu lieu qui sont en cours si vous
regardez par exemple l'effondrement la
biodiversité en europe la disparition
des insectes la disparition des oiseaux
ça c'est des vrais effondrement partiel
pas complet mais partiel le manque d'eau
progressif c'est des effondrements la
destruction d'une partie du couvert
végétal dans certaines zones c'est d
effondrement partiel etc si vous
regardez je pense que ce qui est
derrière l'imaginaire de l'effondrement
01 du lundi soir ou mardi matin c'est en
fait un imaginaire anarchiste qui n'est
pas celui de pablo servi mais c'est un
univers imaginaire anarchiste qui se dit
inconsciemment en fait ce que la
politique n'a pas réussi à faire la
nature va le faire c'est à dire à battre
notre grand ennemi qu'est l'êta donc en
vérité une partie de nos amis collègues
ce blog sont des anars qui rêvent de la
disparition de l'état et qui s'imagine
que après le grand le grand soir
tout ira mieux on pourrait faire des
barbecues sympa dans le jardin ou dans
des jardins partagés
mama mon expérience à moi c'est que les
pays dans lesquels les états ont failli
c'est terrible regardez ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui au liban les gens ont faim à
beyrouth en ce moment à l'heure où nous
parlons regardez ce qui se passe dans le
sahel le mali est un état failli
aujourd'hui
le burkina faso est en train de
s'effondrer ce sont des lieux qui en
fait n'ayant plus de structures
publiques avec un état de droit qui
s'impose avec une loi qui s'impose à
tous à tous sont aidés ce sont des
régions qui
vivent une espèce de régression majeure
vers un système tribal c'est une
reféodalisation de ces sociétés qui est
tout sauf sympathique regardez à quoi
ressemble et l'europe après
l'effondrement de l'empiré romain au
xvième siècle et avant la grande réforme
grégorienne du 11e siècle pendant cinq
siècles l'europe franck c'est pas très
sympathique voilà et donc je crois que
donc donc la réponse est je crois pas à
l'effondrement avec un e majuscule en
revanche je pense qu'il faut être
extrêmement attentif au fait qu'il ya
une accumulation d'effondrement partiel
qui deviennent en partie irréversible
parce que s'il ya trop effondrement on
n'est plus capable de revenir en arrière
c'est ça la vie l'enjeu fondamental une
image que j'utilise volontiers quand je
discute avec des amis collègues ce blog
c'est nous sommes en train de nous
bagarrer sur la paroi interne interne
d'un volcan ce volcan va entrer en
éruption progressivement chaque mètre
gagner pour sortir de la paroisse est un
maître est une véritable victoire parce
que l'un des défauts aussi de l'imaginer
un collabo logique c'est que ça nous
dépossède toute initiative sanou
démobilise en fait c'est du 01 donc
écouté comme on n'arrivera pas à
résoudre complètement la question
écologique ça sert à rien
abandon nounou à l'effondrement et on
fera des barbecues après oui donc il
faut sortir de cette démobilisation là
et se dire chaque mètres gagnés sur la
paroi du volcan est une victoire et donc
il faut avancer après sur les normes
question de la relance est ce que c'est
une relance verte est ce que c'est la
croissance verte je pense que gilberte
ouais c'est alors ma réponse est
globalement c'est du bullshit verte le
président bak ronde à nous enfermer dans
ce débat pour essayer de diviser les
écologistes en france sur le thème moi
macron je suis un humaniste et donc je
fais de la croissance verte et vous vous
êtes des anti humaniste pas ce que
voulait faire de la décroissance côté
aux amish voilà c'est ça le point et
donc en plus c'est méprisant vis-à-vis
des populations année
je crois qu'il faut sortir de ce faux
débat pour la raison suivante c'est que
la croissance verte c'est une utopie qui
postule qu'il est possible d'augmenter
le pib sans augmenter la consommation
d'énergie fossile
sachant que aujourd'hui la croissance du
pib reste à ce jour le meilleur
indicateur l'augmentation des émissions
de co2
donc en fait aujourd'hui on n'a jamais
vu de croissance verte au niveau mondial
on ne voit aucun découplage où c'est
absolument négligeable entre la
consommation d'énergie ou la dissipation
d'énergie d'un côté l'augmentation du
pib de l'autre les hydrocarbures
fossiles qu'on continue de constituer
80% du bouquet énergétique mondial et
les énergies renouvelables continuent
d'être une part relativement faible de
la dissipation énergétique mondiale
il ya bien pardon je termine juste là
dessus parce que c'est un point
important il ya bien eu un découplage
partiel entre l'augmentation du pib d'un
côté et la dissipation ou disons la
combustion de pétrole dans les années 80
à la suite des deux chocs pétroliers des
années 70 c'est à dire que les systèmes
industriels occidentaux se sont dit on
peut pas continuer comme ça nous
dépendons trop du pétrole donc diminuer
notre dépendance vis-à-vis du pétrole
donc survivre que on est capable de
réduire en partie notre dépendance à
l'égard d'un certain type d'énergie par
exemple le pétrole mais ce qu'on a fait
c'est quoi à l'époque on n'a pas
substituer au pétrole un autre type
d'énergie plus propres on a additionné
au pétrole concombre il est déjà
d'autres types d'énergie donc ce qu'on a
su faire dans le passé c'est uniquement
de l'additionnalité ce qu'il faut faire
aujourd'hui cela substitution il faut
remplacer la combustion du cas du
charbon du pétrole et du gaz par des
énergies renouvelables ce que nous ne
faisons pas ou très peu d'énergie
renouvelable
oui évidemment en termes thermodynamique
aucune énergie est parfaitement
renouvelables chez bien d'accord puisque
l'entropie continue d'augmenter mais on
s'entend sur le terme énergie
renouvelable l'éolien le solaire c'est
des énergies qui n'ont pas les mêmes
impacts en termes carbone que le charbon
le pétrole et gaz donc c'est ça l'enjeu
après en terme purement thermodynamique
je suis d'accord bien sûr mais donc
juste pour terminer un est ce qu'il faut
faire de la relance verte et est-ce
qu'il faut croire en la croissance verte
ma réponse est non mais de toutes les
manières
le sujet c'est même plus celui là
puisque vouloir faire de la croissance
du pib ne devrait pas être un objectif
de politique publique en france
aujourd'hui le pub est un très mauvais
indicateur du tout ce que vous cherchez
si je fais un accident sur l'autoroute
j'augmente opib si je pollue une rivière
j'augmente de pub et c est ce qu indique
la drogue si je prends la drogue d'une
certaine manière probablement je sais
pas vous l'êtes mme en clair ça dépend
est ce que c'est un circuit est-ce que
c'est blanchi pour fait part des banques
a insisté mme blanchet part des banques
regardez mais disons que si c'est le
circuit informel ça ne se voit pas dans
les statistiques du pipe bien que par
exemple ocde en 2014 est proposé qu'on
introduise la prostitution dans le pipe
pour gonfler le pipe elle referme cette
parenthèse le point c'est le dire
l'augmentation du pipe de garanties plus
aujourd'hui la création d'emplois
malheureusement depuis les années 90 on
est capable de faire la croissance une
augmentation du pib' sans augmenter
l'emploi donc l'impératif social
aujourd'hui c'est de créer des emplois
on va perdre un million d'emplois
supplémentaires cette année donc là la
grande préoccupation des françaises et
des français aujourd'hui c'est de
retrouver un job est de retrouver un job
qui ait du sens et pas un bol chine job
au sens de du regretté david jalbert or
le gouvernement va nous dit eh bien pour
créer des emplois mois j'augmente le pub
est donc je fais la croissance verte et
donc je suis un écolo humaniste et là le
raisonnement il faut c'est à dire que
pour créer des emplois on n'a pas besoin
de se donner comme indicateur le pipe on
peut se donner simplement la création
d'emplois tels quels et c'est pas ce qui
est en train de faire le gouvernement
aujourd'hui
par exemple le plan de relance français
le plan de relance français lui-même se
donne comme objectif de créer moins de
deux cent mille emplois c'est ridicule
on est en train d'en perdre un milliard
pour 100 milliards d'euros c'est pas mal
non mais non c'est vrai on pourrait
faire beaucoup beaucoup mieux rien que
la rénovation thermique des bâtiments
permettrait de créer au moins cinq cent
mille emplois voire un million entre
conte trois ou quatre ans donc on peut
faire beaucoup beaucoup mieux que ce que
propose le gouvernement qui en fait sous
couvert de faire un plan de relance fait
en vérité un plan d'austérité budgétaire
soit les 100 milliards du plan de
relance il y en a 40 qui proviennent de
l'union budgétaire de l'union européenne
qui viennent pas de l'état français et
sur les 60 restants y en a trente qui
était déjà budgétés donc s'ils n'ont pas
de nouvelles monnaies sur les 30
milliards restants il faudra regarder en
détail dans le projet de loi finances
qui aura été déshabillé pour habiller
pierre puisque ce gouvernement là c'est
en du spécialiste dans la technique
budgétaire de déshabiller paul pour
habiller pierre et donc pardon jacques
auger un coin ça dépend de l'apôtre qui
vous intéresse et donc ce qu'il faut
regarder de près c'est cette question là
et donc moi je veux dire le gouverneur
la banque de france elle nous a prévenus
pendant l'été nous a dit ah on atteint
les 120 % du pime de dette publique
c'est trop donc maintenant il faut faire
l'austérité tiens voilà exactement la
trouvais que c'était c'était quoi
c'était une bombe de cavaliers qui
venait s'utilise huissier de justice
était guen c'était la commission
européenne s'est elle a baissé mais
c'était le fmi qui ont cassé détruit la
société grecque au motif qu'il fallait
faire une austérité budgétaire ce qui a
été complètement contre-productif
puisque finalement ça n'a pas réduit le
ratio dette publique sur pib en grèce
qui est toujours de 180 % aujourd'hui
entre temps le pib grec a été amputé de
25% on a tué les grecs et on a cassé la
société grecque pour plusieurs décennies
le gouvernement français sous couvert de
faire de la relance est en train de
faire la même chose en france de manière
moins violente que ce qu'on a fait aux
grecs mais il n'empêche que c'est
d'austérité budgétaire qui est en train
de faire du gouvernement et sa
l'austérité budgétaire c'est la pire des
solutions quand on entre dans la
déflation c'est ce qu'avait fait le
chancelier and rich froning en 1930
et trois ans après on a huit les au
pouvoir donc en fait la politique
budgétaire mises en place par le
gouvernement actuel est en train de
faire le lit du rassemblement national
en france si on veut que le
rassemblement national gagne en 2022 ou
en 2027 il faut continuer à faire la
politique que met en place macron
aujourd'hui donc à une illusion à
dissiper auprès des françaises et des
français aujourd'hui qui est le croire
que la république en marche et le
rempart contre le fascisme en france
c'est pas vrai elle en est le meilleur
allié puisque la politique était en
train de mettre en oeuvre aujourd'hui sa
politique économique
aujourd'hui ouvre déroule le tapis rouge
à l'arrivée au pouvoir du rassemblement
national lorsque les classes moyennes
françaises seront complètement désespéré
par le marasme économique et la
déflation il finiront par élire un clown
ou une clown comme les allemands 1933
ont élu adolf hitler dur de dire ça
c'est dur non mais c'est très important
il faut comprendre que l'alternative en
2022 ne doit plus être entre la
république en marche et le rassemblement
national puisqu'au fond en réalité ce
sont deux alliés objectifs je ne suis
pas le seul à dire quelqu'un comme mon
ami emmanuel top 10 très bien la
république en marche aujourd'hui avec la
répression policière et la répression
des gilets jaunes met en place des
techniques de répression qui sont celles
de rassemblement national il suffit de
regarder le nombre de main amputées de
visage défiguré de français est mort né
et c'est les techniques du rassemblement
national ça je sais qu est ce que ça
c'est une politique violentes de
répression contre les français on a tiré
avec des balles
en plastique contre les pompiers en
france il faut être conscient de ça j'ai
jamais eu ce timbre
et donc voilà ça c'est ce que
j'imaginais réfère le rassemblement
national si un jour une arrivée au
pouvoir est aux traditionalistes au
rassemblement national non il ya un
certain nombre de catholiques qui errent
parce que ils sont très attachés à la
souveraineté de la france il faut une
confusion entre la souveraineté de
souverainisme ce qu'il faut comprendre
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on a besoin de
reconstruire un programme politique de
souveraineté française qui ne soit pas
du souverainisme au sens de marine le
pen ou de marion maréchal-le pen et ça
c'est la tâche politique des politiques
aujourd'hui dans les deux années qui
nous restent par frick site ça passera
pas par afrique cite moi je ne suis pas
favorable à un freak site pour la raison
simple suivante c'est que déjà dans les
années 90 on n'arrivait pas à
maintenir le taux de change du franc
français sur les marchés internationaux
aujourd'hui les marchés les marchés des
changes internationaux sont beaucoup
plus profond que la taille qu'ils
avaient dans un 90c la france et est une
économie qui est relativement à la
taille du monde est beaucoup plus petit
aujourd'hui que dans les années 90 donc
la solution n'est pas la sortie de la
zone euro la solution c'est une
redéfinition des institutions
européennes éventuellement la scission
de la zone euro en deux zones un e reçu
un euro nord qui pourrait arriver si
l'italie refusait de se voir imposer un
plan d'austérité budgétaire analogue à
celui de la grèce mais certains n'ont
pas apprécié qu il nous reste cinq
minutes j'ai donné je t'ai donné ma
parole pour tout lâcher à 20 heures
eh ben je vais pas la respecter et si je
vais respecter ma parole
je voulais parler de guerres de religion
il va falloir revenir pour en parler
alors oui oui il faut le dire un mot sur
la guerre de religion qu'est ce que les
musulmans vont se fâchait qui est
chrétien ce que les chrétiens on se
fâche et qui est musulman moi j'aimerais
revenir au mont houy je peux dire un mot
là-dessus
je pense que l'écrasante majorité des
musulmans sont des hommes et des femmes
religieux pacifiste
l'islam n'est pas intrinsèquement une
religion belliqueuse mais en islam il y
à un certain nombre de fous furieux qui
utilisent qui instrumentalisent l'islam
à des fins belliqueuses comme ça a été
le cas au sein du christianisme si haut
si le christianisme qui a inventé des
croisades et qu'ils allaient quitte à
les piller et détruire constantinople
pour rapatrier une partie de ses
richesses là à venise par exemple si
vous vous promenez sur la place
saint-marc la piazza san marco à venise
vous y retrouverez les richesses qui
était en fête à constantinople et que
les européens de l'ouest
les croisés on sentait les piller
constantinople donc l'islam n'a pas le
monopole de la violence le christianisme
a aussi malheureusement été capable de
cette violence et le christianisme a dû
apprendre à traverser cette tentation de
la violence pour devenir jeu qui n'est
pas encore complètement aujourd'hui il
doit continuer d'apprendre c'est un
apprentissage qui n'est jamais terminé
devenir une religion de paix l'islam
doit faire cette même traversée slam à
sainté nombre d'enjeux de défis
colossaux de l'intérieur de cette
religion qui sont un rapport au courant
beaucoup moins marqué que celui qui
prévaut aujourd'hui mais l'église
catholique est aussi passé par cette
épreuve là c'est à dire accepter que le
coran soit un texte a été écrit au cours
de différentes décennies de plusieurs
décennies pas par la dictée sous la
dictée de l'ange mais pas un certain
nombre de communautés musulmanes qui
l'ont rédigée à plusieurs mains que l'on
qui a différentes strates dans le
courant dans le coran et qu'il est
légitime pour les intellectuels
musulmans d'étudier le coran comme un
objet culturel un objet historique de la
même manière qu'on étudie par exemple
des grands classiques de la littérature
au 6e siècle bon donc là il ya un enjeu
fondamental à sortir on pourrait dire
d'un certain fondamentalisme
scripturaire dans le rapport au courant
qui aidera à mon avis très très
profondément les communautés musulmanes
à entrer de plain pied dans la modernité
dans la démocratie l'église catholique a
traversé cette épreuve là au cours du
19e et du 20e siècle ça a été la grande
crise moderniste en 1905 en france
j'espère que c'est irréversible il ya
évidemment malheureusement des courants
à l'intérieur du christianisme qui
voudraient revenir à une lecture
fondamentaliste des écritures de la
bible sur la liste dirait
fondamentalistes 1 il ya des communautés
chrétiennes aux états unis par exemple
qui continue d'enseigner à leur enfant
que le monde a été créé en sept jours de
manière littérale donc une lecture
littéraliste de la bible ça c'est
catastrophique et c'est absolument pas
compatible avec l'expérience chrétienne
l'espérance chrétienne n'est pas du tout
de cet endroit là elle est
intrinsèquement contraire la lecture
littéraliste de la mine en fait à
l'intérieur des écritures
de dunes du premier testament donc des
écritures juive et du nouveau testament
les écritures chrétienne il y a des tas
d'indicés littéraire qui constituent des
antidotes pour nous prévenir contre la
tentation d'une lecture littérale des
écritures l'islam doit faire cet
apprentissage est à cette condition là
pourra devenir lui aussi
une religion de paix comme il a vocation
à devenir les deux dernières questions
il 19h59 c'est pas des questions c'est
nous conseillez trois livres un
conseiller trois livres la communauté et
un conseil pour les jeunes générations
trois livres je dirais premièrement le
bouquin que j'ai cités tout à l'heure
qui est une monnaie écologique de
d'alain grandjean et nicolas dufresne on
n'a pas eu le temps d'en parler
complètement mais mes deux amis ils font
des tas de propositions très
intéressantes pour financer la
transition écologique deuxième je dirais
peut-être le bouquin que j'ai mentionné
tout à l'heure des timothy sned qui
s'appelle de vos tutoriaux freedom et
qui décrit ce que j'ai raconté à propos
des îles ont des racines idéologiques
fasciste de poutine et de la très grande
dépendance de 30 à l'égard des
oligarques russes le troisième je dirais
peut-être un excellent ouvrage qui a été
écrit qui a été publiée l'an dernier par
l'un de mes amis qui est prof à
stellenbosch en afrique du sud qui
s'appelle marc ce wheeling le bouquin
s'intitule de justin abrutis et c'est
une description par un homme qui connaît
très bien les sciences politiques des
différentes options pour la mise en
oeuvre concrète effective pragmatique de
la rue construction écologique c'est
écrit en anglais mais ça vaut vraiment
la peine d'aller regarder ça ça c'est
trois bouquins le conseil pour la jeune
génération
je dirais un de traverser la tentation
de s'enfermer dans un procès vis-à-vis
de ma génération je vois beaucoup de
jeunes qui sont pris part ça c'est le
procès aux ok boomer vous n'avez plus
rien à nous apprendre puisque vous nous
laisser une planète inhabitable
même pas une vengeance une espèce de
mépris et d'indifférence voilà ça sag
est une partie de la jeunesse
aujourd'hui je crois qu'elle doit
absolument se dire qu'elle n'est pas en
mesure on n'a pas le temps de lui
laisser à elle toute seule le devoir de
réinventer l'eau chaude donc ce qu'elle
doit faire à mon avis c'est de se
chercher des alliés dans la génération
du dessus parce que ce n'est pas vrai
que tous les membres de la génération du
sud ont de ma génération sont tous
pourris c'est évidemment pas vrai donc
s'attache à elle c'est de se chercher
des alliés et danzé d'entrer dans un
travail collaboratif
intergénérationnel pour mener à bien la
reconstruction écologique gaël giraud
merci merci à vous
[Musique]